the Durham report came out many of you
heard about the details it effectively
confirms that there was a soft coup from
the intelligence agencies against a
sitting president and man does it rock
my confidence in this country because
many of these people are not going to be
held to account but we do have new
developments rep Anna Paulina Luna has
filed for the expulsion of Adam Schiff
who lied repeatedly about evidence and
proof that the Trump family was involved
in some kind of conspiracy to subvert
this United States so I'm really excited
to see that breaking news and we're
going to be talking a lot about this
because we've got Donald Trump Jr
hanging out with us normally I do the uh
the joining us later but I just want to
jump straight into us because I think
there's going to be the bulk of the
conversation what's currently happening
we do have a bunch of other news stories
too so we'll just go right into it
before we get started my friends head
over to castbrew.com to support our work
Casper is our coffee brand and Company
we're using this company is going to be
a cultural Hub we're hoping to launch a
bunch of coffee shops all over the all
over the country that's our dream we
you've got one currently in the works
it's ambitious but we're hoping to get
there with your support by buying
castbrew coffee at castbrew.com we will
make this happen we've invested heavily
in this so far we're talking like I
probably shouldn't say it but I think
we're near like half a million dollars
invested in launching this this program
already because I really do think
getting people in various cities to sit
together for a cup of coffee is going to
give us a cultural foothold in a lot of
locations so casper.com you can pick up
your rise with Alberto Junior breakfast
blend only whole being available but we
do have the cast Brew Coffee Club sign
up today and you'll get three bags every
single month also don't forget here's
the big one go to timcast.com click join
us become a member then you'll get
access to our private Discord server
where not only will you be hanging out
with like-minded individuals but if
you're a member at 10 bucks for at least
six months you can submit questions and
call into our uncensored after show and
if you sign up for at least 25 right now
you will get instant access to the VIP
chat where you can submit questions and
at about 10 10 pm tonight we're going to
go to the uncensored members only show
at timcast.com where we will take your
calls so you can talk to all of us here
at timcast including our guests which I
think many people are really excited
there's a lot of questions around uh
what happened with the Derm report so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
as I already mentioned joining us
tonight to talk about this is the man
himself Donald Trump Jr what's going on
guys how you doing I think everybody
knows who you are do you want to do a
quick intro I suppose uh Donald Trump Jr
there you go all right thanks for
hanging out this should be good to be
with you man you're you're the uh uh
even before the show we're talking about
your family Being Framed by politicians
by intelligence agencies for being
Traders and spies is the most it's it's
it's it's bigger than Watergate it's
it's insane like significantly and when
you look at the amount of people that
were involved the resources that took
place to create this thing the level of
people Tim that knew uh and we're all in
on it and we're just just fine with that
I mean it's not just you know Comey is
the director of the CIA but Obama knew
and Biden knew and Hillary new and
everyone knew and it didn't matter yeah
well that's the Anna Paulina stuff's
incredible because like yeah Adam Schiff
I remember this just and I take it
pretty personally because I was the guy
that they said they're I'm gonna go to
jail for life they were going to try me
for treason also a crime punishable by
death you know Minor Details for me at
this point it's just another Tuesday but
you know that guy was on TV every day
saying he had seen the evidence he had
it I was going to jail for life and
you're sitting there being like I don't
even understand what's going on and like
let alone uh that this is happening but
they could do that that the media could
so gleefully run with it as though it's
the gospel without actually anything
there they want awards for it well
that's the interesting I think my
father's actually suing uh some of them
I think it's the Pulitzer committee
because you know the Washington Post I
think the New York Times they won
Pulitzer prizes for the journalism
surrounding uh Russia Russia Russia but
that's unfair none of it actually
happened I'm sorry that's unfair you
called it journalism
the propaganda around Russia well that's
honestly at this point that's what they
are you can see that you you can see uh
you know the joy they take when someone
who's actually a dissenting voice like a
Tucker Carlson comes off the air uh you
could see it when you know I guess it
was Jake tapper's voice was cracking
last week after the CNN town hall
because you know even with weeks of
preparation to try to take out Donald
Trump it didn't work out quite like they
had planned and you know it was really
interesting perhaps to him like just
seeing the Durham report like the just
Total Blackout on mainstream media like
no one's even talking about it it's like
it didn't even happen it it it's like
we're just gonna not even talk about it
because if it's not good for the
narrative not only will we not cover it
a little bit we won't even acknowledge
it the the Democracy folks we heard a
lot of screaming about democracy and
Trump's the greatest threat to democracy
like they're awfully silent because this
feels like an actual threat to democracy
and yet I don't hear anyone bitching
about it so we'll do it so this is gonna
be fun thanks for joining us I'm very
excited uh it's an honor and a privilege
sir we've got Seamus Coughlin yeah but
we were complaining about it all day
yesterday I was playing about it on my
podcast which is called shamer by the
way all can check that out on Rumble my
name is Seamus Coughlin I create
cartoons on a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we're going to be
releasing a cartoon tomorrow that I
think you all are going to enjoy if you
want to go check that out and subscribe
and we have a website freedomtunes.com
if you want to support what we're doing
you can become a member there thank you
we've got Hannah Claire bremelo hanging
out yeah hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow
I'm a writer for timcast.com you should
ignore Sheamus's podcast and go to
gymcast.com and click on the read tab I
think I'll just go check out my Rumble
podcast by the way
I am a trump
podcast first I am the master of
Shameless plugs five minutes
you can't turn that crap off if you have
those jeans okay just relax okay so I
gotta do that and I don't do that often
but I gotta you know I I gotta play the
trump card if we're if we're all doing
gratuitous plus quite frankly shaver is
the greatest podcast I let it go I let
it go at first I didn't even include it
in my intro but if everyone else is
plugging I'm gonna plug that's why we're
here baby it's your show I just have the
triggered podcast on Rumble where you
know do much of the same it's a long
form uh long-form version of a lot of
the rants that you've probably people
have been watching me do on social for a
while and uh uh had some fun with that
just enjoy the platform and being able
to say whatever I want and it's awesome
and I do like YouTube what time do you
stream uh I go uh six o'clock Mondays
and Thursdays oh nice I do Tuesdays and
Thursdays at six o'clock so on Thursdays
you guys are sitting to mine all right
uh and then we got search press on all
the buttons yeah today is going to be
fun yeah it should be good yeah I'm
excited yeah we've been talking about
this for a little while
yeah and I called in a couple weeks ago
and that was that was cool and sort of
unexpected Alex was like hey you want to
call and I was like yeah sure yeah and
uh he's like I'm gonna call him on the
phone I was like okay I guess yeah but
you ended up joining through the Discord
and uh well I want to jump to the story
but I just have to uh say it was a a
beautiful moment when you just yelled I
am a trump
I'm not gonna be out plugged
DC Drano on Twitter check this out
breaking news GOP rep Anna Paulina Luna
submits house resolution to expel rep
Adam Schiff from Congress in light of
Durham report findings showing his
involvement with illegal spying on U.S
president it's a resolution says
resolved that pursuant to Article 1
Section 5 Clause 2 the Constitution of
the United States Representative Adam
Schiff be and he hereby is expelled from
the House of Representatives now I I'm
not convinced they'll actually do it no
unfortunately they should do it and
outside of the the spying I do want to
mention that he published the private
information of an American journalist
once again in an attempt to smear your
family but let's jump into this tell me
there's a lot more to it I mean the
whole thing I remember I've I've done 50
hours of testimony before the various
committees house intelligence Senate
intelligence twice house Judiciary and
when he was on house intelligence and
doing that you know I was in front of
that committee and I got out it was like
I got in at like 9 A.M I think I got out
at 7 p.m 7 30 and I go and I was like
okay guys what happened today and I'm
looking at my Twitter at 7 30 at night
and it's like literally every bathroom
break there was a leak literally like on
you know this is what's going on in the
room and he's just out there it has to
be him right because like you've never
met someone you guys never met a camera
he didn't love and they're more than you
know gleefully carry his nonsense uh and
I was just like oh my God like my
lawyers weren't allowed to take their
phones into the room but he can go leak
to people from the intelligence
committee I mean these people shouldn't
have classified you know documentation
it's no different than like swallow who
was sleeping with a Chinese spot It's
Perfectly Natural to leave him on the
intelligence committee I'm like I don't
understand but you know that was going
on I was I was part of three of the big
you know the walls are closing in
Bombshells you you heard many of those
but three of the big ones were me and
one of them was that I had somehow
gotten the Julian Assange uh emails or
information that Clinton emailed before
but the reality is like some random dude
like dm'd him to me I think it was or
emailed them to me it just literally
like spamming like possible Trump email
accounts and like it ended up in my
inbox and I'm looking and I'm like I
don't have I didn't have these things
before they came out out and work but
they took it was like 14 right like
August 14th or whatever the date was
right they they just deleted the one in
the email so it looked like I had it on
August 4th wow it was released on like
August 8th or August 10th but you delete
the one from 14 it looked like I had it
four days before the rest of the world
not six days after the rest of the world
you know because it's you get a lot of
that spam you know it was just totally
like that was a gotcha moment it's known
now because we have the emails that we
handed over and we have the emails they
used in evidence and it's like no
there's not even a correction you know
there's not even a correction it's like
it's the it's like it's still real and
so it was just that constant lies yes my
Time Magazine cover was truly special so
this is vox.com from 2017. it says
red-handed times latest cover captures
how bad things are for Donald Trump uh
the Russia Scandal hits home by David
Von is it drill everybody said and um I
I think at this point it's now been
about six years uh since This Time
Magazine cover if
red-handed what nothing nothing happened
it was it was all nonsense yeah the
whole thing was a lie but it didn't but
again that didn't matter and that's the
thing I mean even then for us and for me
it's like Well there must be something
to it I mean you know the FBI is saying
these things the CRA like these are
they're maybe leave their honorable
institutions yeah I I believe that I
have friends in law enforcement and now
I know I now make the distinction sort
of between the door kickers and the
bureaucrats right the door kickers like
they come up to me all the time it's
like I can't believe what's going on
it's disgusting and like but like they
also know if they say anything they're
fired or they'll never get promoted just
like they're doing in the military if
you don't if you don't take the vax
times 12 like you're no longer a fighter
pilot we'll just put it
someone else who checks a bunch of boxes
I gotta be careful but it sounds like
cowardly it is but you know that's
unfortunately you know now the game
again no one's talking about this story
right now it's kind of a big deal I mean
watergate's a big deal they still talk
about Watergate as being a big deal the
people who you know worked on a
Watergate they haven't really done much
since then but they still hold this
legendary status for some reason and you
know they've been commenting Bob
Woodward and others have been commenting
on this story for six years as though
they're the foremost authority on it no
it's all nonsense yeah but like where's
where's like the oh we got this wrong
where's the Mia call like it doesn't
even matter you know that's never coming
no it's never coming because journalism
is dead and that's why it's so important
what you guys do and what I try to do
what it I'm sure what you do as well I
am a journalist on Tuesdays and
Thursdays at 6 p.m I appreciated you're
welcome
um you know well we're all sort of in
this together because the reality is
like we're taking on media and you know
some of these things that I I do
actually genuinely believe were once
Noble institutions but like
man
you've gone downhill quick well here's
the evil these people are look I think
that uh when your dad gets reelected we
need an AG who is going to launch
criminal probes I'm not saying every
journalist I'm not saying every Democrat
I'm not saying every uh member of the
intelligence agency or federal law
enforcement are criminals I'm saying it
is clear that there was an attempt a
seditious conspiracy now they're trying
to I'll I'll phrase it this way right
now what do we know there's something
called a standalone complex are you
familiar with the term I've heard of the
term I'm not I think I think it
originates from Ghost in the Shell it's
a it's a manga in anime but the idea is
when a bunch of people all do something
in in a way that looks like a conspiracy
like if if there's a crowd of people and
also and everybody stands up you might
think it was coordinated but it's not
that's what we can say happened right
now but I will say this all of these
people who pushed the lies Hillary
Clinton making these false claims the
FBI then chasing after evidence that was
not correct the manipulation of evidence
to further fisa warrants suggests
probable cause that there was a
seditious conspiracy correct at the bare
minimum I am hoping that we actually see
a real AG get in when your dad gets
reelected and he just says we're gonna
start filing some criminal
investigations likely some criminal
indictments and then these people end up
getting charged I think Adam Schiff is
is criminally culpable for going on TV
over and over again trying to subvert
this country and and so distrust in our
institutions well and so just reverse it
right and reverse the parties for a
second
if if Republicans did what Adam Schiff
did they'd be in the gulags right now I
mean someone would be in gitmo uh you
know I use you know I I don't want to
necessarily talk about myself that way
the whole time but like you know if I
was Hunter Biden right like they
wouldn't be removing the team at the IRS
to hand it over to the doj because they
had a whistleblower that whistleblower
would be Beyond reproach
uh you know if I was on video I mean you
know if I did one of the hundreds of
degenerate things like it would be
disqualifying not just for me but for my
father but for him it's okay you know
millions of dollars the shell entities
that were magically formed uh to do
business the second Joe Biden had
authority to do only in the countries
that Joe Biden had any kind of authority
where he could manipulate an outcome
like magically these people are all of a
sudden business people I mean we got in
trouble for building buildings when I
think there's a pretty solid record that
our family's been building buildings for
60 years uh it's you know it's that you
know the the two-tiered levels and
two-tier system of justice right now
that's just so flagrant it's so in your
face uh even those who may hate Trump or
me or whatever like I don't think that
anyone can objectively look at it maybe
they won't say it in in polite company
but when they're sitting there by
themselves at night being like okay well
there's a lot of BS here is uh when your
dad gets reelected I don't wanna I don't
know if you speak for him and I and I do
think there's something silly of being
like Trump Jr is here let me ask you
what your dad said yeah no I and I don't
because you know a lot of candidly
there's so much every day like I I
couldn't I couldn't keep up with the
insanity to begin with right there's not
enough time in the I'm just hoping that
uh he fires everybody yeah classically
classic Trump you're fired a little
Cobra to all yeah to all the bureaucrats
I hope that a real AG comes in and says
this country needs a fresh start these
these this corruption's got to go yeah
well listen I I do know this and talking
to him I mean coming in as an outsider
was great but you also have the pitfalls
of that which is again you can't fathom
that uh honestly even like a Democrat
politician at the time now we're you
know everything's in hindsight right so
it feels like we're so much like
obviously you know Wuhan lab leak right
like of course it was like now I always
believed that was the point of origin
but you know did we really think uh you
know our health officials would
literally subvert the health of the
American people they would like you know
we didn't we know that now but at the
time you know what I mean uh you know
one of the things they gave my father a
lot of stuff over uh January 6th I don't
know what I can say on YouTube or not
but I don't think it's controversial but
why didn't he pardon people in these
seven days between that and like we
didn't know they didn't release any
information we were told it was a
violent this we weren't shown any video
two years later we finally get the
videos because Republicans are able to
release that but there's a reason they
controlled that information you can see
that happen then but in that period of
time you actually didn't know much I
actually think if we look at these the
CNN debate that your dad had with
Caitlin Collins it was uh he answered
answered rather well she said why did
you wait three hours to say you know no
violence and you he pulls out the tweets
and he's like half an hour after they
breached I said no violence no
violations and then are you going to
pardon people and he said I'll take a
look at it some people obviously did bad
things and they shouldn't be pardon he's
completely right yeah No One Believes
you should be able to go punch a cop
randomly but like if you're getting a
tour through the capitol but you know
it's a little different right the police
opened the door for you and let you in
why are you being criminally charged
um you know the video the sound bites
that you hear from that I mean I I think
it demands much further investigation
and honestly the bigger thing is
frankly almost regardless of even if you
did punch a cut I think you're still
entitled to Due Process yeah and that's
the problem that seems to be totally
missing meaning you know due process
doesn't mean we put you in jail for two
years or maybe we'll deal with it
someday and you know even with all of
this stuff going on even with all the
conspiracy theories that have come true
even with everything that we now know
they want to cast a wider net around
January 6 I'm like really like that's
what you're gonna look into not not
people who have real power and influence
in Government manipulating whether it's
you know and I think I it's not election
interference but this was designed to
hurt trump it made midterms harder those
of us who you know I've become a junkie
at this at the time I probably wasn't
right we build buildings that's what we
did like I was into it I was almost
reasonably political but not like I am
now so you know you're sitting there the
average person trying to put food on
their table and they're listening to
five minutes of news a day it's like
well okay there must be something to it
I thought that and I was a Target I was
I was probably the number two target of
them after my father well so let me ask
you what was a
I I suppose it's two-part question what
was the first time you realized they
were lying like they were coming after
you like something was happening and and
how did you feel like it was back 2017
or something I you know it's interesting
you know I don't actually remember I
mean I you start seeing and you're like
wait a second like
that's pretty obvious and again
initially even with this stuff I was
like well yeah I made who the hell knows
right they they get you that way a lot
right there's you know some you know one
of the alt-right characters you know
they make it seem like that's half the
country it's nonsense right there's
seven of them out there that you know
but they're like they got a selfie with
Dunn Jr like I took 1700 selfies that
day like I I don't know who that person
is but it's like we're best friends and
the media will run with that so you know
it's like well I don't know maybe
someone was doing something bad and who
knows maybe they have a picture with me
because I took a a click line because
you're a public figure I took 150
pictures in in a five minute period it
doesn't mean I actually know the person
it doesn't mean I could even tell you
when that happened because I was so
swamped with it but so you're like well
maybe peripherally there was something I
know I didn't do anything but then you
start seeing it further and you start
really I was like wait a minute I'm
actually the right-handed on cover of
Time Magazine and shifts on TV every day
lying about it I'm like wait a second
and and again then for better or worse I
guess you know
I I have a little bit of the Trump Gene
and that kicked in and I was like we I'm
not running from this I'm just gonna
engage my lawyers man they my lawyers
were not in love with me for a while
when all that stuff happened like the
first time when that stuff happened like
I got on TV that night and they're like
you can't get on TV like anything you
say I was like dude I'm not going to be
called a traitor and and take it I don't
care if if this gets me into trouble
telling the truth and being open and I
did it I put out the you know the DMs
like I guess the DMS from Wikileaks and
Assange that I was like here are this
like like I'm not what am I supposed to
do I opened a DM that someone sent me
like that I don't know like am I
supposed to and by the way you know I
also didn't come I wouldn't have even
thought about these things necessarily
at the time right like it's just a
different mindset now it's like okay
like what what's the setup what's the
angle I think about these things now at
the time I certainly didn't but I
realized how much more nefarious it is
but I agree with you I mean it's the
most frustrating thing in the world when
you have lawyers being like you can't
defend yourself yeah and they did and I
I just ignored them and for two years
they're like you're gonna get and
finally they they can came up to me like
there go you were right I go wait a
minute they're like you know what if you
would have curled up in the corner over
there and you know sucked your thumb
crying for mommy like it it would have
meant nothing you could be worse it
would have actually been worse right
it's it's the capitulation you see that
with like cancel culture right the
second like okay I'm sorry oh the sorry
bloody water there's no honor in it
right there's no if you're trying to do
the right thing that's actually your
admission of guilt to them because it it
doesn't have to be real to begin with
right the accusation can be total BS but
if they say it enough they put it on the
cover of Time Magazine there must be
some truth to it you then try to be okay
let's just settle it down I'm gonna
apologize no no that's the first mistake
because now they got you because you've
admitted that you actually were wrong
and there's no coming back from it
they're not dealing you know honorably
they're not it's not an arm's length
like let's do the right thing exactly
and this is something that conservatives
and Republicans both as individual
citizens and political leaders have
really failed that for such a very long
time left Winger will come at you and
say you're a racist when you're trying
to have a discussion on something like
Health Care welfare policy border
security basic math somewhere where it's
completely relevant and so often
Republicans would respond to that not by
saying all right I'm going to completely
disregard that non-sequitur and continue
the conversation about something of
substance that we were actually
discussing they would go no no no I'm
not raised all my best friends are black
I've never done anything that would ever
offend anyone I let me let me play by
your rules and then your dad comes
around and do American politics and when
these people start asking him these
ridiculous questions and framing things
in a ridiculous way he's like shut up
you're stupid and it's beautiful Rosie
O'Donnell thing was exactly what you're
talking about I think Rosie O'Donnell
but I think that's really important
screaming and cheering I was there and
that was like I'm just like that was
actually when I was like oh he's gonna
win this thing it was interesting when
he called Rosie O'Donnell I knew because
well it wasn't even when he did it was
the reaction of the crowd you know it's
interesting like you know the Brash
billionaire from New York City that
lives in gilded Trump Tower it's like he
still had that connection with the
regular people and it was from you know
being in construction sites a lot like
he didn't lock himself in an office all
the time and like listen to the
executive he'd walk a construction site
and talk you know with a guy that's
putting up sheetrock it's like would you
ever think about this this is how to get
a little bit more ceiling height or
whatever and like so we always had those
kind of connections with those guys and
he just got it and that's when I
realized
just how much he got it and it was the
reaction from those people you notice
when like when he did his uh his opening
speech here June 16th 2015 I only
remember because it's my daughter's
birthday
um
no one said anything about the Mexican
rapist comments because of course that's
going on right now we see that at levels
like you know we've ever had never seen
before at the border of you know the
amount of those coyotes yeah all of that
stuff like but everyone thinks that like
that flared up that day it wasn't it was
like two weeks later
when like he actually started gaining
and all of a sudden like oh my God he
could win that's when it became racist
because everyone knew it was real so
everyone thinks that it was like that
was the reaction to the speech no no it
was the reaction to the success of
everything that he was doing about two
weeks later when the outrage cycle
started and all of a sudden it became
racist as opposed to just factually draw
him with their number one slur he's a
racist then perhaps that would undercut
a success and part of what was so
hilarious about that is during Trump's
campaign they overused the word racism
so much they had to move on to a new
phrase right in 2016 after he got
elected they started calling everything
white supremacist because the word
racist didn't mean anything did you guys
see the stats last week it was like
Washington Post and New York Times like
700 and a thousand percent respectively
since like 20. yes the use of the word
it's just because it's just clickbait
and listen I think social media is part
of that right like I'm I'm not going to
pretend I'm not guilty of some of these
things but like you know everything's to
get that click and you got to make it a
little bit more inflammatory like the
problem with it is like now do I believe
that racism still exists sure I just
don't think it's the cause of a solution
for all of life's problems like it it's
not you know I I travel the country I've
I haven't experienced any of it I
haven't seen it I see tens of thousands
of people a month like all over the
place and and yet there is actual racism
still but when everyone's branded a
racist when you're talking about
economics or math and you're called a
racist because that's like the the easy
button of the political left it does a
huge disservice to those who are
actually afflicted by that and that's
not everyone and if you know I I think
what exactly what we're talking about
right now in more ways than just the
racism issue like every grievance
they've screamed for seven years the top
of their lungs it's just falling on deaf
ears at this point and people are tired
of it correct again which does a
disservice to the small fraction of
people who are actually genuinely
Afflicted either and or you know or
because yeah you now when I get called
like I don't even respond like people
like they said you were racist you know
they tried doing it to my brother last
week he's an anti-semit it's like that's
gonna make you know Thanksgiving really
awkward with my sister who's Orthodox
Jewish like I'm like like what are you
talking about it doesn't matter yeah
like they can just say it you know well
you were near someone who once said this
I'm like did I say it like it's just you
disregard these people at this point I
suppose when someone comes up to me and
says something that sounds like I'll be
like you're not a serious person exactly
exactly yeah I mean if if they had any
genuine concern for the groups of people
for whom they claim to stand and who
they claim to defend and they would be
really careful about the bombastic
claims that they made in the media to
everyone about groups of people that
they didn't like or politicians they
didn't like because all they've done is
discredit themselves over the past
several years so even if they were
fighting for these supposedly
marginalized groups well who would
believe them when they offered up a
solution anyway
you would yeah I mean you made the point
about serious people you're right but
like who at this point
who is a serious person when it comes to
this stuff because like they're all
doing it right it's not like there's a
couple guys that are Beyond like you
know the reality is and maybe again I
think it's why they were so gleeful
about Tucker because he he did take on
both sides he called out Republican
establishment you know you saw the I
mean the thing that was so frustrating
for me as someone who's super anti this
insane War uh in in Ukraine uh and just
funding it in perpetuity to let people
die I love my my father's answer on CNN
Town Hall but was like the Republicans
spoke to Politico or the hill or some
other leftist thing uncondition of
anonymity now that Tucker Carlson's no
longer on Fox we can gleefully continue
to perpetuate the war in Ukraine without
fear of reprisal for I mean like wait
like you're a Republican senator you
were elected to do this you know despite
what Mitch McConnell says when he's like
Republicans it's their number one issue
like Mitch I've spent a lot more time
with real Republicans like on the ground
and like it's not a top 10 issue for
almost any of them
uh but they're they're gleeful that they
can continue to support an unpopular war
with the people that elected them
because no one's going to actually be
there calling them out because of the
uni party or that you know it's insane I
think one of the things they're very
scared of when uh your dad was on with
uh debating Caitlyn Collins he said he
would end the war in Ukraine in a day
and we had been talking about that about
a week or two before and I said the same
thing I think so he gets in there and he
shuts the whole thing down the issue is
they don't want the war to stop no of
course the worst profit you know how
much money they're making again it's 130
million you know the Pentagon misplaced
220 billion right like if you missed 10
six bucks on your taxes right they want
to go after you if you over a 600 venmo
transaction 601 the IRS is going to
audit you with their 87 000 new agents
you know
but the Pentagon can misplace 220
billion dollars and no one's even like
huh like I wonder where it went it like
it's just like oh yeah you you know how
much money that is like but if they
misplaced it they had a good reason you
just have to trust because while I'm
saying the reality is whatever the 130
is that we've publicly funded you know
we also didn't re we didn't think I did
because I just don't believe anything
they say about the average person also
didn't believe that we had boots on the
ground in Ukraine either because it
wasn't congressionally approved and it
certainly wouldn't be popular with the
American people who you know until
Ukraine sort of became the new religion
of the left replacing uh you know Lord
fauci and kovid as the religion and
demigod uh of the left for the last few
years like the average American is not
for these wars they they're trying to
drum that back up and it's because our
generals that's their retirement plan we
get on the board of Lockheed Martin the
way to keep that job is to continue to
sell missiles you don't continue to sell
missiles if you're not actually using
them because you you know and now we're
depleting our stockpiles to do that and
that's everyone's get rich quick scheme
when they retire let's let's talk about
some uh some contemporary politics
because I have this story from Newsweek
and it is one of the greatest headlines
I've ever seen the fake news publish
John fetterman's question at Senate
hearing leaves witness speechless not in
the way that you think not in the way
that Newsweek would have you believe and
this is exactly it they want you to
believe that his question was so good so
strong that the witness was like how do
I have nothing to say when in reality
what happened was John fetterman didn't
say anything coherent at all you play it
sputtering and you play it because like
how much you want to bet they didn't put
it in the article oh my gosh without a
question here let's go no I know but
like is it actually going to be in it
they went to go to Hawaii's after there
was a crash of your bank and I couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe it so I I
went up on the internet and it's like it
did happen
it did happen
in June
and in U.S history collapsed collapsed
and chose to go to Hawaii this isn't the
good part yeah I've never been to Hawaii
I don't think they're going to show it I
think you're right I think they're gonna
actually crashed a bank you know so
given that this is I'm the last person I
don't have much left to ask but I will
you know let me ask you this one
particular question no I think they're
going to put to everyone here on that
and it is it is an inside is it an
inside joke had no no matter how
incompetent or how greedy the government
will always bail you out when your bank
crashes I mean everyone has to do that
right you know everyone has to realize
that no matter no matter how bad I
behave no matter how big my my uh race
is my my bonuses and everything you know
we will come in and bail it because we
can't crash the economy watch the way SV
bib was argued that it was going to
crack what did he just say I I have no
idea I actually it's not even the crazy
part I did a short that's not the crazy
part because I did one there's a minute
and 10 seconds I just did a commentary
for like you know Facebook and social on
it and I'll do it on the podcast
tomorrow I guess like but it's a it's a
minute and 10 seconds of utter insanity
and like Federman you know I I've spent
a lot of time on this one because I'm
one of the few guys I've been called uh
you know not a racist on John fetterman
but I was called an ableist because I
went after him which is them admitting
he's disabled by the way exactly well
for those of you who don't know that
means you discriminate against those
with disabilities and I just don't think
it's ever going to be popular with the
American people to not expect basic
cognitive function from a United States
Center this is someone who could vote to
send your children to war it's someone
who's voting on trillions of dollars and
will and he'll rubber stamp the Democrat
thing do you have the actual quote Yeah
you want to play yeah yeah play it it's
just too good
staggering responsive responsibility
that the the head of a bank could
literally could literally crash our
economy
astonishing that's like if you have I
mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in
they guaranteed a guaranteed way to be
saved by again by no matter no matter if
I have my how you know so it's it's you
know isn't it appropriate that the those
kinds of this kind of control should be
more stricter
speechless prevent this kind of thing
from going or should we just go on and
start bailing and sailing whoever Bank
regardless of how however there's
however conduct is
it's like when you're trying to talk to
a girl you like you know you get nervous
I love how his look at the guy's like oh
he can't respond I'm like because you're
an imbecile
requirements you know for a a a a a
hungry family has to to have these this
kind of penalties are these some kinds
of word working uh required shouldn't
you have a working requirement after we
sell your bank with billions of your
bank
because they seem to be more preoccupied
uh when then snap uh and requirements
for works for Hungry people but not
about for protecting the tax the tax
papers you know that will fail no matter
whatever does about a bank to crash it
what
when he got elected the media was happy
to say hey this is a guy that could be
for 2024. I mean well I mean now we have
an imbecile in office right now so like
exactly
I want everybody to remember what you
just heard from this man and I want to
show it what Newsweek wrote yes here's
what Newsweek writes quote Republicans
want a work requirement for SNAP for
Hungry families shouldn't you have a
working requirement after we bail out
your bank fetterman asked the at the end
of the hearing he does that's those were
not the words that came out of his mouth
not even a little bit those words The
Washington Post did the same thing uh
where they he the guy I guess did a
correction well yesterday I tweeted a
quote provided to me by the Senator's
office without checking it against the
video because he gave this glowing quote
that actually made sense I don't
necessarily agree with you know what was
in it but it's what they wrote it flowed
it's what they wrote like and they're
just covering it and again I know
they'll call me an ableist once again
but I do not think it's unreasonable for
the American public the voting public to
expect basic cognitive function this is
a United States Senator guys like this
is not someone and I don't I don't think
you led Joe Biden do it either but like
you wouldn't let this guy drive you in
an Uber car like yeah you certainly
fighting gets lost on agent is confused
there is something sad about it because
he is so pathetic in that well that's
that honestly that's the hard part
that's why I think it was easy to get
people to hate Hillary it's hard it's
hard though it's hard to hate you about
like whether the corrupt like you look
at him you can't if you're human you
can't help but feel bad for him because
you realize he has no idea where he is
it's the same thing with jumping he's so
clearly trying to recall I mean a lot of
uh officials memorize their statement
that they're going to have that's not
unusual but he is struggling so
desperately to recall what he is
supposed to be saying not just like oh
I'm getting stage fright I'm forgetting
my lines like he is not there and in
some ways that is unnerving that there's
a group of people who can see this
person who's clearly sick and suffering
and saying go out there and try and you
know oh and that's weird and hit the
talking points he's being used as a pawn
because he's not hated like like a
Hillary was right now I'd argue that
he's probably far more effective in
actually delivering some of the insanity
of the radical left policies because
he'll sign anything thing you put in
front of him because he does not know
where he is he's also incapable of
reasoning about no no but hear me out no
I think you're right like whoever is in
charge whether it's Obama whether it's
Susan Rice whether it's one of these you
know radicals Obama felt the same way
but he just wasn't going to destroy his
legacy signing this stuff in they're
happy to throw Joe under the bus because
like what's his legacy going to be but
they're actually furthering that
Insanity do we really believe that like
an 85 year old Irish Catholic guy like
you know the trans thing it's the social
justice cause of this generation like I
don't know I don't think anyone believes
that but he'll say it like I certainly
don't think an Irish Catholic believes
that stuff well you're certainly not
allowed to yeah but she's not you're not
a real Catholic if you believe you
should transition kids that's not even a
question right that's not even our only
question like Catholics do not believe
in transgenderism at all but he's also
pro-abortion and he's also pro-abortion
Joe Biden is not a practicing Catholic
and he hasn't been for decades because
he doesn't give a cent to church
teaching he doesn't believe in what the
Catholic Church teaches Sheamus is a
Shiite that's right I can see that but I
think that's like a lot of America I
think it's like a lot of Americans
though a lot of Americans identify as
Christian and don't you know live out
those practices at all it's because a
lot of men identify as women you know I
know they don't live out those practices
either listen the reality it seems like
we can identify us a lot more than we we
could have a few years ago so I'm going
to give someone who's not quite 100
practicing Catholic I'm gonna give them
a little bit more slack than the people
who you know are going to force me to
say some sort of pronoun
is trans Catholic he does identify his
cow Fetter men identifies as a senator
and the responses and I know it sounds
like a joke this is not a joke I'm being
serious he runs for the Senate he is not
capable of being a senator I feel bad
for him because you know he really he
always wanted this he has a stroke I I
it's a horrible thing and I feel bad and
now he's still feel you know what's
happening
what I'm trying to get it when I say he
identifies as a senator is much in the
way a leftist will go to someone and say
yes you're exactly what you think you
are they're going to this man and being
like yeah you're a senator you're a
senator stamp it here when he's clearly
incapable he is not he's effective but
the thing and people don't realize that
and they're they've been lying to people
about this they knew this about the
stroke
they could have had Conor lamb who was a
congressman and again I don't agree with
a lot of his positions but at least he's
present you know at least
there's a there's a gerbil in the
hamster wheel like moving around where
it's not with him but they said this is
a guy that we can get him to win it
doesn't matter if he's capable of
thought because all he has to do is
rubber stamp but look Chuck Schumer says
and it also talks about the the issues
with elections now I won't talk about
elections now maybe we'll do it in the
later hour because and again I won't say
anything but like do we really think
that like the people of Pennsylvania
were shown this man and like oh yeah
that's my guy but or do we think there
was a ballot harvesting operation and
there you know there's that uh joke from
I think it was what's the guy's name was
it John Dye I hope I'm getting his name
wrong he said uh why how come when uh if
lizzo is so beautiful how come women get
so mad when I say you look like lizzo
yeah yes it's because she's healthy
they're lying right this is what I mean
the same people who are going to lizzo
and saying oh you're so beautiful are
the people going to John fetterman be
like you're a great Senator Yep they're
not being honest with us because they're
putting the feelings of the individual
who wishes they were healthy beautiful
or a senator in front of the actual
responsibilities of a person in that
position yeah and this is one of the
very sad Paradigm shifts that is leading
to the slow death of the West what
people used to do
is they would encourage you when you
were young to try to figure out what you
could give to the world what is your
vocation what are you meant for what can
you provide to others then it was
shifted towards what can you do for
yourself how can you prove that you're
impressive how can you be in a position
that's comfortable for you and so what
we end up with is a situation where you
have someone who is either in steep
cognitive decline as Joe Biden is but
wanted to be the president or his
handlers wanted him to be the president
and so it's mean to tell him he can't or
someone like John fetterman who is quite
clearly cognitively impaired but who
wants to be a senator and so no one
around him was willing to say Hey you
actually can't do that job I don't even
know that he wants it I don't know to be
fair
I think he was bullied into it they're
like this is our best chance and now
you're gonna sit there for six years and
get through it you don't really have to
show up you can wear shorts on the floor
of the Senate and that your hoodies we
love your sneakers I'm not one that like
overdresses it's not my like but like I
don't know there's still no respect for
that Institution and like they don't
care about that anymore like that's all
gone well let me just add one caveat to
what I'm saying then you you could very
much be right that they bullied him into
this they thought he'd be someone who
could represent their interests well and
I think that's likely the case even with
somebody like Joe Biden but the American
people should be able to see hey the
purpose of a job isn't to make someone
feel special for having that job the
purpose of a job is to provide something
to society this man cannot provide to us
as the people what a senator is supposed
to provide because he's clearly disabled
right he's just not meant for that
position there's nothing wrong with
being disabled it doesn't make you a bad
person there's nothing wrong in the
moral sense right you're not less
valuable as a person but it does mean
there are certain jobs that aren't open
to you because they require a high
degree of competence yeah I think what
you're but that's mean but that's mean
to say I think that's when you let him
perform brain surgery on you would you
let you know I'd end up like him there
are things that she can't do because he
is uh cognitively impaired but I think
we're seeing this happen with Joe Biden
with fetterman and we're seeing it with
Dianne Feinstein in Congress like she by
the way enough where where Democrats are
openly talking about maybe she should
step down we know she's not going to
seek another term maybe she is not
healthy enough to continue in her job
but instead they're like well she took
three months off and we're going to
welcome her back we're going to pretend
things are fine I mean it is she was
gone three years ago it was known like
it's one of the biggest sort of Untold
secrets of Washington I know like
they're like oh yeah she's got dementia
like it's like people in DC people in
power understand that this is the case
like they talk about it openly they want
to hold on to the seat that's for
everyone around them I mean this was
like the with Ruth Bader Ginsburg right
there was a huge like I think it was
kind of a joke but like that she already
had retired and all of her staff were
writing all of her comments anyways
right like this was something that
people joked about and I think it's the
same thing with with as many people and
in fact in fact if you can have a person
like John fetterman in the senate seat
and get the policy you want through why
wouldn't you pick another candidate who
is easily manipulated right if you're a
Handler and you can't personally hold
public office for whatever reason but
you can find someone who you can
basically pop it and get your policies
through why wouldn't you do that someone
else is taking the blows that you don't
have to absorb but you're getting your
way you're holding on to the power well
I mean it's funny how similar these
politicians are to pop stars today I
mean there's just people behind the
scenes writing all of their material for
them making all of the money off of them
and they're just the face of the
operation and they really do run it like
a franchise once that person is beyond
the point of really being able to
perform they hop them up on
performance-enhancing drugs so that they
can keep doing so it's horribly cruel
you guys saw Dianne Feinstein forgot she
was gone right like the big story was
that she said what do you mean I've been
here the whole time and they're like
also have her face appears to be
paralyzed
she was out for pneumonia and apparently
we're not gonna talk I wrote about it in
my book uh when I wrote liberal
privilege like Joe Biden's had two brain
aneurysms like if you ask any guy you
know that's a brain surgeon uh you ask a
neurologist about like the statistical
probability of there not being serious
issues with one annual
it's almost like non-existent with two
and then when you see it and you see the
eyes you're and it's just dead or hear
him talk or you he or you see the fear
even worse when when he when you know he
forgets where he is or can't get off the
stage because it's not just a little
confusion there's actually a moment of
panic and you see it and so do our
enemies and so the people that are
making decisions abroad and you know
it's literally influencing our space on
the world right now because you know
that's the nature of predation right
Predators see weakness uh and they
pounce that's right what they do like
that's that's a story as old as
any living yeah and now Joe Biden is
competing with himself to become our
nation's oldest president and you know
of course your father is is older as
well but I don't really know that we
want to elect our second oldest
president who already gets lost on stage
but Trump's clearly younger cognitively
right like 85 years old that can run
circles around my 40 year old that's not
joking this is a relative thing and I
get I'm not just saying that because my
father but like if you put you sit in a
room with my father it's like okay like
you know he can hold court for three
hours he can go on CNN like could you
would you put Joe Biden on Newsmax oh my
gosh no you can't do that no one would
even watches did you guys hear the audio
of one of the Secret Service members
being like okay we're just gonna walk
here and you're gonna stand on that X
like well he still misses it he's still
missing I think there's a video I could
be wrong so I don't want to get fact
checked but I think there was one way
he's like somewhere a blind guy
literally was like no no you have to
come over here they were a blind man was
guiding him and he still got it wrong
like it's a blind leading The Binding
literally yeah well but have you guys
considered this that he just has a
speech impediment and you're being
bullies because that's what I've been
told all of these
there are reliable and credible sources
that have told me that I am an ableist
so so that could be just leaning into it
speech impediment is apparently also a
disability and no it yes it is not that
you don't you don't forget where you are
because of a speech impediment you don't
forget the name of the person you're
trying to introduce it's not the stutter
you see you don't forget where you know
that the state that you're in
you maybe have a hard time getting it
out for a second but you don't say the
wrong place
over time I mean Joe Biden has been in
public office four years we have heard
him testify from the floor a hundred
times you can see recordings of it he is
not okay he's even different from when
he was the VP right like you can see a
very serious decline in his speech
that's not just a speech impediment also
a speech impediment doesn't make you say
poor kids are just as bright and
talented as white kids right that's not
a speech impact character that's just
that's just
I got Harry Lane I got hairy legs I'm
going to sniff this child I'm like you
know the sniffing children thing it's
like that should be disqualified
the fact that everyone knows it's a real
problem it's talked about on a daily
basis and yet he continues to do it
because he's incapable of stopping yep
right there's no control there that's a
basic part like I have I'm sure I have
bad habits if they get me in trouble not
like that
to correct that I do what I can to try
to correct it you know you know you
trying not to curse because we're on
YouTube and not rumble or whatever it is
and I you know I don't do a great job of
that but like I can usually get by
reasonably well he's in K like stop
sniffing children like it's not that
hard exactly like I'm trying to figure
out which speech impediment makes you
ramble about Corn Pop and sniff kids and
I I haven't discovered I've webmd'd
myself to death but I haven't found
anything you actually have
all this reminds me of that scene from
Doctor Strange Love with the dudes
riding the bomb down yeah like we know
everything's falling apart and I'm I'm
laughing but I'm also laughing because
y'all are laughing like our president
can't think properly his brain no longer
works we have two senators who are
incapable and have suffered medical they
all have some kind of brain issue
inhibiting them from functioning and
we're all sitting here laughing as
though we are riding this bottom all the
way down
yes well that's true but no but I mean
remember the the stuff they did with
Trump I mean every like tele
psychologist every teller neurologist oh
my God Trump he he held a banister to
walk down a slippery ramp like no he's
just smart enough to hold a banister so
he doesn't fall and give them like you
know slip and fall like Joe bidenfelt
like there's like three times
flight of stairs it's Air Force One he
knows the cameras are on and he still
can't get it right like he fell they
were WebMD your dad they're like oh my
gosh he's in the later stages of
dementia and Alzheimer's miraculously he
can give a three-hour speech like
impromptu off the cuff
no that affected there but he has these
issues apparently is what I'm told I
like the armchair psychology uh he has
narcissistic personality disorder he is
just this terrible human being you can
see it everywhere or like recently I saw
headline that was like he didn't wish
his wife a Happy Mother's Day on social
media obviously there are problems in
that marriage like what a strange way to
measure someone that they're not
performing the way you want them to as
opposed to Joe Biden who is actively
falling down and getting lost this is
not the same thing it's not you know
again whether it's the corruption
whether it's that I mean again I don't
always say like imagine Don Jr was
Hunter Biden I have a feeling the things
that are non-issues would be serious
issues no I think so if you know if if
Trump made the daily mistakes of Joe
Biden if he made the errors if he
tripped if he fell if he did if he did
things that were normal and they could
see what wait oh it it looked like he
flinched he must that must have been a
mini stroke you know the the amount of
just Insanity trying to you know back
into a medical condition I watched it
for the four years and two years during
the primaries well it's it's also
interesting you've touched on this a few
times here already but the way the media
treats you and your siblings versus the
way that they treat Hunter Biden it's
unbelievable right and one thing I
remember constantly hearing during
Trump's presidency any time anyone
brought up any of your success was oh
well they they had a rich father of
course they became successful because
when you have a rich dad your success
story explain Hunter explain Hunter
Biden to me listen he's an over
performing crackhead he's actually
the Chinese gave Hunter Biden a billion
dollars to invest because they
apparently invest a lot with crackheads
or or they were looking for some
diversity and inclusion and they
realized that the people they didn't
want just competent people to invest in
you know the Chinese are many things but
they're not stupid
they don't give someone with no
investment history or prowess unless
they're buying something so of course
they were but the fact that that's not
brought up right like they're buying the
Chinese didn't do diligence they're
looking to diversify they need some
degenerate
you know crackheads to to Really round
out their Investment Portfolio they're
underrepresented they're buying crack
are we pushing the line honestly let's
be serious the reason why they're
investing in him is one I think you're
correct they're buying something
influence of his father but they're
buying something really really great
this is the perfect investment
opportunity for an adversary because not
only are you putting money into
something that's of value to you but you
have tremendous leverage and that punter
is a crackhead and that if they ever
cross you you can really yeah you can
release the information well no because
all the me the information's out in
Armenia doesn't care yeah but is there
one of our enemies that again I want to
know and I'd like to see just out of
just curiosity imagine like the stuff
that Hunter was like you know maybe I'm
not gonna video this one
this may be a little too far for video
yeah what it's Hunter
do we have an enemy that doesn't have a
hunter Biden laptop and do they have
more because again you saw the
revelations last week right you know 15
entities all conducting business in
places none of the bidens had ever
conducted business all set up literally
the day after he became vice president
all only in the areas where Joe Biden
would have authority to do this you know
the brother has a piece of the deal the
girlfriend has a piece of the deal the
grandchild like do any of them have
international business experience
including Hunter and the brother but
like the entire family is on the payroll
of these companies and then you see this
week Joe Biden used his second veto to
veto bipartisan legislation that was
going against China like the fact that
our media won't even ask the question
it's like hey do you think that maybe
like you'd veto bipartisan legislative
bipartisan legislation doesn't just
happen that much in Washington these
days but Joe Biden is going to use it as
a veto much like it like China it's the
greatest investment they've ever made a
billion dollars to China is nothing I
was out we were we were talking about
this a little bit earlier the hunter
Biden laptop and then the question came
up like what do you think Don Junior's
got in his laptop and I was like I bet
it's really boring I bet it's like by
the way if it was documents if it wasn't
you'd know by now because it would have
leaked because I'm other than my father
the most subpoenaed person in the
history of the United States government
and they've Skeen all my phones and they
and again if there was that stuff on
there it wouldn't be suppressed it
wouldn't be hidden it would have leaked
I'm probably the second most vetted
person in the history of the United
States at this point did they did they
take your devices oh yeah they I mean
they you know they get they get copies
of it I've had to do that I mean as
early as recently as last week I had to
give another copy of my thing because
that's the New York Ag and their
Perpetual witch hunts like I've had no
idea is crazy it's insane because and
they just fundraise off of it right the
no jury in New York's had ever let Trump
go because just the social stigma of
like you know they'll dock some like
they tried doing the Kyle writtenhouse
they they'll figure out how to make it
you can't get a fair jury these people
are fear for their lives I almost
understand it I think it's sick and not
everyone has like you know my general
like let's call it underdeveloped sense
of self-preservation we'll go out there
and like
screw you and screw you and like fight
like other people like
they don't have that it's not that easy
we need to all develop that we need to
become unafraid uh until we do we got a
big problem because they can take out
they can pick off the guys that'll stand
out so here's what it feels like to me
uh
surface level simplified I feel like uh
your dad sees something in this country
as he sees the issues they're fairly
obvious he's talked about him for
decades and then he's like I'm gonna run
for president I'm gonna fix these things
and the the
moneyed interests that would be harmed
by this reacted massively in fear so
you've got corporations that make money
off cheap immigrant labor you've got
corporations that make money off
Outsourcing jobs to foreign countries
you've got foreign adversaries that were
extracting wealth and value from our
country and bringing our jobs and
overseas and then all of a sudden uh
Donald Trump comes in and says that the
famous Michael Moore speech where he
says to the auto manufacturers I will
put a tariff on your cars at 30 and no
one will ever buy it again and then what
do we see during the Trump
Administration
or the return of auto manufacturing to
Michigan bringing I believe three
billion dollars yeah that's that's
historic we see the Abraham Accords and
I'll tell you uh recently I had a guy
tell me I was at a poker table he said
there's no way you like Trump because
some lady was like this guy likes Trump
and she was saying it like kind of in a
funny way like she was nice she was she
was she liked your dad too and he was
like impossible and then I mentioned
North Korea Crossing into North Korea
and the DMZ with no security detail I
mean all the other guys there got the
binoculars from like 30 miles out
looking through it like I said this is
history this is these are historic peace
deals we saw the economy booming and
they reject it and they refuse and what
do we get instead it really does feel
almost like a yin yang night and day
kind of thing where with the Trump
Administration far from perfect we have
an end of wars in the Middle East an end
of Isis we have troops being withdrawn
from Syria we have peace in in certain
parts of the Middle East we have an
attempted peace with North Korea we have
a booming American economy and it all
inverts the moment Joe Biden gets in
office yeah I think that's what's
scariest to me was just again you think
of this thing you know the American
economy it's this big ship like in two
years they eliminated it all like they
got I mean when you think about what's
going on right now with interest rates
uh when you think about what's going on
with inflation like you know as some of
these mortgages start resetting in these
five and seven years arms start
resetting like you know people are gonna
get crushed man I don't think anyone
understands just like like we're at like
2008 and perhaps worse uh you know
levels again and it's only a matter of
time now I think you know the powers
that be are doing whatever they can to
delay it to try to blame it on you know
whoever beats Trump or whatever later on
but like they the country is going to go
through a lot of pain because of the
stupid decisions to try to do this and
by the way you know the Republican donor
class and that billionaire Cloud
oftentimes just as guilty it's like well
you know yeah we're really anti-china
unless we can get our widget for one
cent cheaper in which case yep you know
so like I'm not pretending like you know
it's only the Democrats doing these
things but it's also why the Republican
donor class was like well we don't want
to support Trump this time it's like why
because he made you bring in like
American labors and put Americans to
work because we created energy
Independence like like now we're getting
that we we still need it because like
let's not kid ourselves the batteries
you know they don't produce themselves
the child labor uh child slave labor in
Africa isn't quite producing uh you know
the the dream of everyone in America
having a car and you know of course they
their ESG scores aren't affected by that
because they subcontracted out so you
know you hire a hitman instead of doing
the Dirty Work yourself and it doesn't
count you mentioned Abraham of course
like yeah that was the Holy Grail of
like geopolitical politics for decades
and everyone was like it could never get
done it's never gonna happen Trump goes
like why well we've been dealing with
this same with North Korea we've been
dealing with the issue for 40 years and
it's like well have you like actually
sat down in the room with the people now
we would never do that well like it's
why do we believe the experts the
experts don't know like now that we
I mean those of us who are following the
the hoaxes Russia gate and stuff you
know early on my attitude was like oh
wow this stuff's interesting I mean is
could this be true I remember meeting
with a journalist in New York and saying
like is this stuff real like you know
tell me like the stuff that you can't
report what are you working on and she's
like it's it's real it's true and I was
like wow really and I'm like it's crazy
it's real because they wanted it to be
real and then sure enough I'm like hey
wait a minute and as time goes on then
you get the Ukraine Gate scandal the
fake impeachments imagine what the news
would have been imagine what the news
should have been with a roaring economy
with manufacturing coming back with the
with the new U.S trade deal the usmca
with the the crushing of Isis the media
was was inverting everything they called
the leader of Isis on a steer scholar a
man murdered and raped women a guy who
burned journalists yes like you'd think
the media scholar yeah austere religious
guy I remember reading that and
you know I think we were talking with
some of your team downstairs before we
started I was like there's days I wait
like I feel like I gotta be the star of
The Truman Show like they're just
screwing with me like they it can't be
real I can't wait for you to find the
camera yeah I know like I'm gonna find
the camera one day because it's like I'm
being punked like I have to be yeah
because like there was no other time in
history where we think we'd having the
conversations there's no other time you
know in history we think the hills that
the Democrat Party is willing to die on
these days are those are those Ingersoll
Lockwood books real like is that a real
thing you know what I'm talking about
that story about those books from the
1800s that talk about Baron Trump oh
yeah I think they wanted for present do
you know about this no so I'm like this
has got to be fake it's got to be
someone pregnant supposedly they're
books that were written by a guy named
Ingersoll Lockwood in the 1800s that
talk about Baron Trump who lives on
Fifth Avenue in in New York City and he
runs for president and then uh a bunch
of anarchists and socialists from the
Lower East Side of Manhattan like rushed
to like protest or something like that
I don't know I you know I I watch Like
The Simpsons episode they called some of
these things pretty well they those were
pretty amazing uh they were apparently
they're it's a surrealistic a novel from
1896. uh Americans are protesting
corrupt election process while the
president's hometown of New York City is
fearing the collapse of the Republic
after the transition of Presidential
Power I I can't believe this is real
okay I just I'm sorry I can't I feel
like I'm gonna talk about this and then
someone's gonna be bad can you believe
Tim Poole fell for that hoax that 4chan
did or something like that and that's
the problem I mean there's plenty of
things like you can try to you can't
even discern what's real and what's not
some of these things anymore because
there's so much out there it spread so
rapidly and the problem is some of the
stuff that we see in the real world
today is so asinine that the hoaxes
actually seem almost normal by
comparison you're like oh yeah that
totally fits with everything I'm seeing
elsewhere so talking about this uh novel
and he says that uh Baron Trump's
Adventures begin with begin in Russia
and the uh the guides are they think
they think uh diresters for he gets
sorry he gets directions from the master
of all Masters a man named Don
because now it's starting to sound a
little bit like okay I can't I can't we
got a loop in Russia like the baron the
baron Trump novels are two children's
novels written in 1889 and 1893 by
Ingersoll Lockwood they remained obscure
until 2017 when they received me
attention for perceived similarities
between their protagonist and U.S
president Donald Trump dude who's the
guy that found those books and that's on
Wikipedia not that I trust anything on
Wikipedia because I think that's one of
the more biased things out there but
well you're just jealous that it's not
uh not Junior it's a bear
I'm just gonna be yeah no that's fine
please let it be someone else you want
to know something's funny I tweeted this
and the left these people have no sense
of humor they don't understand so I I
posted a picture of Joe Biden super
ripped with aviators and they didn't say
anything there was no of course no
conservative was like Tim you're
obsessed you're an occult Joe Biden's
not good they knew it was a silly AI
thing and then after the town hall I did
Donald Trump going Super Saiyan and he's
all ripped and then all the leftists are
like it's a cult it's a cult and I'm
like dude it's a joke but I tweeted this
do you know what you know what Donald
Trump means
I don't Herald of the world ruler wow
yeah I don't even want to tell him
he may like that one too much well it's
your name too yeah I guess that's true
Donald means World ruler I guess in like
Scottish Gaelic or something like that
wow and Trump means that the trumpeting
sound of like the arrival the so it's
the arrival of the world yeah just you
saying that may drive them crazy it does
and and I tweeted it and they were like
it's a cult and I'm like I am not
literally saying I support this man as a
god Emperor I'm making a joke it's a
meme
but but anyway you talk about like The
Truman Show and stuff and I immediately
thought about the baron Trump novels
it's amazing I haven't I haven't even
seen that like we got to be living
inside I can't keep track of all the
conspirations here I mean like most of
them end up coming true but like you
know there's there's only so much time
in the day and there is a lot of yeah
yeah it's definitely weird because these
books are real you know it's not like
someone as far as we know produce them
later they didn't rate them after the
fact no every now and again though you
have these moments that that are such a
shock and they're so surreal but they're
they're still so wonderful I really was
depressingly resigned to the idea that
Hillary was going to win in 2016. I
really thought she had it and then on
Election night I started to see that she
wasn't and I started to see everyone on
CNN and msnbs freaking out and crying
and I thought oh my God
crazy and then I remember
when he walked out on stage two you
can't always get what you want and he's
just smiling and I'm thinking this dude
Hillary Clinton spent her entire life
pulling every string she needed to and
behaving as cynically as possible so
that she could get this position and
then he this guy just wakes up one day
and he's like I think I could be
president you know what I think I'm
gonna do it and he runs and he beats her
it was like the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen what was that like for
you guys in the lead up to that decision
that was pretty sure I mean I did a lot
obviously on the campaign Trail I mean
but what's what's really interesting
about it is like in 2016 like you felt
the enthusiasm you saw that love you saw
everything like but I was like hey man
we're gonna over perform but
how do you beat that machine right yeah
if you asked me in 2020 on the same
exact time I was like oh we got this
like the enthusiasm was greater the
crowds were greater the energy was
greater people more like if you asked me
there was nothing that seemed off at
that time no and that and that's why I'm
so skeptical of so much of the other
stuff and I and you know from a
perspective thing like I did a 104
rallies in October of 2020. wow like
October mathematically possible it's
basically four a day oh my God uh for
for a month you know like and when I say
rally you know 300 to a thousand people
maybe five thousand people at certain
ones you know but that's not like a a
press hit that was actually like live so
like I was everywhere you know I could
use three four states a day sometimes
like you know so you saw that and if you
ask me between the two which one it was
like not even close
and you know again you know just from uh
so then what was election night 2020
like uh you know very again it felt
great and then it was like you know five
states all of a sudden they're counting
there and it was like yep and that's
when I was like uh oh that that's the
you know something's going on and you
know yeah so how do you feel going into
this round do you have more skepticism
do you feel like your strategy has
changed I think it's a little early
um
for that but I think people
again I think what the perhaps the most
important thing that Trump did was just
open people's eyes to that you know
Trump derangement syndrome
you know just got people to say the
quiet Parts out loud I think there was a
lot of subversive stuff going on
probably for decades
yeah excuse me
um I think there was a lot of the you
know the the nonsense that we see the
whether it's Russia Russia Russia
whether it's you know the lies about you
know the Wuhan lab leagues and all I
think that was going on far longer than
we ever imagined but it took Trump
to get them to fully lose their minds
and just to put all the cards on the
table for everyone else to see it you
know again I'm a junkie I now follow
that stuff I don't not a junkie like
Hunter I'm just like a political Junkies
in 30 seconds we'll have Don juniors are
talking
and you know so we're getting it but I
think it's forcing regular people you
know I I I don't make any you know
pretend I don't get where I came from
the son of a billionaire like but if I'm
pissed off filling up my car
what's that doing to regular guys you
know if I take my kids and I bring them
to the grocery store because they want
me to cook something for dinner whatever
it is I'm like damn
like it
if gas was twice as expensive it
probably wouldn't change my habits I'd
be pissed but it's not going to change
like there's people it it really affects
them and the fact that I understand this
and it it seems like the vast majority
of Democrats in Congress do not like I'm
not supposed to understand that and yet
it's just it's sort of obvious now you
know my outdoor hobbies and stuff like
that I hang out with a lot of good good
redneck Americans and stuff like that
until I see it but like I think it took
Trump to get this I think it also
perhaps took a Joe Biden to reinforce
how fragile it is interesting how
quickly it can disappear like I said I
sort of started alluding to it earlier
when I was like you know it feels like a
big ship but it really isn't I mean two
years it was like within days this
policy we're gonna get through to that
we're not going to finish the wall we
can send 130 billion to recraine but we
can't finish the wall for three uh how
dare you want to stop drug trafficking
at the Border in human trafficking you
just crack yeah do you think that'll be
the effect of Joe Biden's presidency
that people who think that think of
themselves as moderate maybe lean left
will say but we can't have another four
years I mean like and by the way if it
if it's not
then perhaps we're already lost right
because like if people you know I I
don't I can't find someone who could
credibly you know maybe they'll do it on
you know CNN or whatever but like you
know name a metric
that we're performing better as a
country than we were two years ago and
by the way even in the midst of a
pandemic basically you know but then you
know Karine jump here she can get on
stage Joe Biden has created what no
she's not look she can't make eye
contact with anyone in the room because
like it's just the body language to tell
like she knows she's lying he created
more jobs than any president in America
like and no one feels that no one
believes that allowing people to go back
to work after you shut them out of their
jobs you know saying you know your
Starbucks is totally a you know required
thing but Church isn't you know like
it's it's a necessary thing but it like
I don't think anyone believes that take
a look at this chart this is from the
New York Post when Biden takes office
inflation skyrockets this is the only
chart it's just the one I just quickly
Google searched there's one that is is
more
um
it's more granular gets down into the
days and I remember seeing this and it
talks about wages and inflation the
moment Joe Biden is elected he signs a
bunch of executive orders and we see
inflation go straight up and wages go
straight down and I've had people say oh
well the reason that Spike happens
nothing with Biden it's because of the
debt spending and coven and I'm like no
no no you can't say that and then see
the change happen literally right after
the signing of like 30 executive orders
something he did right when he got an
office caused this flip to happen yep or
unless you're arguing some Grand
conspiracy where Trump set some
executive orders to expire I don't think
anyone can believe that credibly because
again I don't think that there's anyone
even on the conservative side that was
actually really working with Trump to
help him I think they did everything
they could to subvert him including the
FED including you know I I don't think
he'd pretend that those guys were
working I think you know in the midst of
a pandemic yeah you had to do some
spending to keep businesses open that's
fine but they want to keep that going in
perpetuity uh you know it it's it it
just doesn't work the math doesn't
you're gonna have to pay the piper
sometime
I think I actually may have found real
clear politics this is from Real Clear
Politics take a look at this
so right when Joe Biden gets inaugurated
you can see wages drop way down and
inflation spikes it's incredible yeah
Biden Administration right when he comes
in
crashes yeah
you know and that's the sad thing I mean
you know bringing those jobs back to
America and you know I I I went to
boarding school but I went to boarding
school and like sort of you know central
Pennsylvania sort of old sort of
industrial Town one of those towns that
you know time forgot and again growing
up it was the home of Firestone Tires
and like Mrs Smith's pies and stuff like
that you just see these you know
dilapidated buildings and stuff like
that and it's just like man these were
once like great like thriving areas that
are just run down and it's like bringing
those jobs back bringing back American
manufacturing bringing back car
manufacturing to Detroit like it was
happening like it's not rocket science
like you can do it if you even care a
little bit if you can break away from
the billionaires if you can you can
actually do this still in America and
then to just to watch that reversal
to what man it's just to what degree is
it an intentional
is it is it a controlled demolition
right how could it not be man like you
know what I mean like again all Joe
Biden had to do was nothing
you know let the ship sail continue it
out you know they can't you know they
they even say you know they want it well
we and then a year later they're like
where we're gonna bring back maybe
Trump's policy on the border because
well yeah because it was always working
you had to do something different right
withdrawal of Afghanistan a true
disgrace you know you you couldn't just
leave it alone the way they had it you
had to change it so you could have the
headline of you did it faster so instead
of doing it during the winter when
they're hiding in caves you do it during
the fighting season when they can come
and take over a couple in 12 days but
they never they couldn't see it coming
I'm like I'm not a military expert by
let's just assume I know jack about
Afghanistan like oh I saw that coming
it's on purpose you know like they saw
it coming but they needed the sound bite
knowing that there was no consequence
because the media big Tech would make
sure the story was that Joe Biden did
this he's a great hero he he had to mess
it up he couldn't leave it alone they
needed to make it their own and they
knew that if they made it their own even
if it's a disaster they got full
coverage by the media of how one
wonderful and great he is just like
those same people are telling you that
he created more jobs than any president
in history
I think the American people believe it
because I feel like a lot of Americans
remember what happened in Afghanistan
and they will not be able to forget it I
I you know again I think we're chipping
away slowly you know I think it's why
they're going to do what they can to
prevent the inevitable you know from
happening because you know when it gets
really bad when you see that 08 kind of
Crash you know like they changed the
definition of recession a year ago like
what is a recession if it was under
Trump you know if you met this level of
not GDP growth for this amount of time
at any other point in time it's history
they go well that's just the way we've
kind of done it but it it's it's not
really like etched in stone but I was
like but you mean you're saying that now
because we've hit that level that puts
us in a quote-unquote recession but if
it was Trump like you wouldn't be
changing the definition to like pretend
like we're not in a recession even
though every metric we've used
historically forever has been met to say
we are there they would make the rules
more strict if it was
it's technically a recession it really
is much worse than growth was lower than
five percent this year so really it's a
recession I do love when Obama was like
what do you say there's no magic wand
you can't get four percent growth
Abracadabra
but it is but again it didn't take it
didn't take that much and again this is
with
even a lot of the people on our own side
working against us and I mean that's
sort of the miracle of the Trump
residency is like he actually knocked
some pretty serious wins despite the
Republicans working I mean Paul Ryan and
the things that they were I don't want
to do that like if we build a wall like
we may upset a couple people like who
hate us like and put us in the gulags
like I can't have that I'm like really
like do you think there are people like
that like if your dad wins next year are
there similar people who you would
advise him to be careful of who might
work against him oh I think 100 I think
he knows who probably most of those
people are yeah
you know listen I'd say you know the
vast majority of of the United States
Senate uh you know there's a couple
great guys in there but you know a tiny
handful uh I think you know the honestly
it'd be much easier to name people who
aren't on the list than who are
interesting right I mean no but like if
we're gonna be real I think there's a
couple great people in Congress you know
meaning the house uh but again that's a
small part of that machine right the
unelected bureaucrats I mean it's
definitely I mean I'm not sure I can
name one that isn't you know but no they
did that they entren you know Obama did
that very well they entrench a bunch of
people that are career and you try to
change the job role that you know that's
not appointed by the president so you
can't touch them their life they could
be the most incompetent people in the
world but they got ten years so they can
stay there like it makes it really
difficult to clean house it's the least
Merit you know there's no meritocracy in
Washington DC if you can get in those
positions uh you know you're there for
life I mean if you married at anything
you wouldn't be in DC of course yeah
exactly yeah you know if you're doing
five in the market but I think that's
the other part of the attack on Trump
which is like you know we don't really
want someone from out of the system ever
doing this again like you know that
system works really well for us and
we'll keep you know we we want to make
part of it's the statement of hey if
you're another successful guy who's done
this in the real world and you want to
get into politics and like you know
imagine what they try to do to you know
elon's not born in America so he can't
do it but if it was someone like that
that wanted to run for president yeah
I've done what I've you know I put
people on Mars and you know yada yada
maybe I'll do this imagine the Revolt
they don't want that that's a threat to
the system that they've created that has
been very beneficial to them but no one
else and that's why it's so important
they don't get away with what they did
to Trump with the FBI attacking them but
this this means because that will send
the example to the American people that
they will beat you if you try to stand
up against I I I don't think firing
these people is enough no I I I agree
with you I just don't listen
I have my opinions I have what I'd like
to have happen yeah uh Which is far more
grave than what would ever happen you
know the problem is you actually still
have to play Within the realm of reality
right yeah and you know I don't it
doesn't mean I'm compromising my
position my position may be X but I just
know it ain't happening nothing's gonna
happen no I want to keep pushing I want
to make sure we get people who elected
who can actually try to do that I'm
gonna do whatever I can to make that
happen but like you know sometimes we
get caught up on this is what I want and
if we don't do that I got 99 of what I
want and it's like business you don't
get it you don't yeah you never get 100
of what you want Republicans do that
poorly we we take our toys home and we
cry having like 99 of what we wanted
rather than taking the win and like
we'll work on the one percent starting
in five minutes yeah you know the
Democrats get 51 and they're starting on
the next one the next day they take the
win move on they take the win they move
on they take the win move on and it's a
death by a Thousand Cuts they get where
they want we don't do that well we don't
play that game well and you know and I
understand it's a lot of it's because
we're principled but I think a big part
of print you know my principle is
actually getting where I want to be
realistically and I don't want to blow
important wins because I didn't get a
hundred percent of what I wanted in that
and you know people oh you're a sellout
I'm like no I just this is how we
actually get some win instead of zero
wins whatsoever which is what we're
really good at getting I I don't know if
you would know but I'm curious your
thoughts on a potential vice
presidential pick for I think I think
it's too early right now
um so I I there hasn't been much
listen you know there I I'd want someone
in there I just tasked a clean clean
house in certain things right
there's a couple guys out there that
could do that maybe specifically
um yeah well listen I'm not gonna go
because I know what the media will then
and Donald Trump Jr's undercutting his
father and he's announcing the game like
but
you're getting warmer you know I don't
know you know maybe we put Tim pool in
charge of doj just cleaning it
lock him up Tim no but I think I think
you get something I got people like
Trump also who don't care anymore the
people some of the people who've been
wronged yeah okay the people who they
try to break who they tried to bankrupt
and probably did in many cases like you
know I'm not saying all you know because
there's some that again you gotta but
like there's some of those people that
now understand that their life meant
nothing to these people and when that
happens to you you know maybe like it
happened to me like okay you know what
like I don't want to curse but you know
Fu and we're gonna like we don't care
and I think again that's the most
important that you know as much of a
just total reset not again that that
word will be used against me is oh my
God conspiracy you're not allowed to say
start from scratch and eliminate as much
of that bureaucracy as possible have
people willing to be like you know this
guy's the North Korea he was an expert
he led the North Korea policy for four
years I was like what'd you do
well Trump's doing it all wrong but why
well hold on maybe because you've LED it
for 40 years but you've accomplished
nothing in four years like but you don't
what you got to do is you got to sit
them down and say what would you say you
do here
yeah
it'll feel like yeah like office space
all over again I want to say you know uh
I despise politics I would never want to
be involved people jokingly say like
maybe you know why don't you run why
don't more people run if you're so
pissed off and I'm like I just want to
go anywhere near it I can't believe
people want to I told Carrie like I
can't believe you want to keep running
she's talking about the Senate but if uh
Donald Trump said look you complain so
much about these people we'll put you in
charge of all the indictments it's yours
now I built yes yes
conspiracy theorists who have been far
more right who have been far more
correct than uh all of our Elite and
educated media just let them you know
give them each a task and just be like
have at it I mean frankly informed in
conspiracy theorists are a redundancy
these days you know the conspiracy
theorists they're bad in like a thousand
is for us I'm concerned absolutely even
Elon Muskie said recently in an
interview he was like well a lot of them
turned out to be right and the guy's
like which ones and he goes the hunter
Biden laptop and then the interviewer
goes okay well that was true yeah stop
bringing it up I always talk about Wuhan
lably because it was so obvious like Jon
Stewart goes on yeah whole Baron says it
of course it happens
the only one more obvious than that was
Jesse Smollett because like but like of
course it didn't like you're telling me
it came from three feet outside of the
bio lab that studies the exact virus
that leads like crazy by Magic like it
just and if you were
if you were a doctor and you questioned
like the there was like there was no
other answer there was no other option
of course it was that like in the former
CDC director said that pressure was put
on him to not acknowledge that publicly
there was a uh scientific paper yeah
he's a conspiracy theorist I think it
was South China university in Beijing or
whatever it's called where they said
called if we did it no they post they
published it yeah
this is early on they said bats had bit
bitten people and urinated on people and
that's what they think caused the leak
and then they quickly retract this we
got rid of it because probably the CCP
came in and said do you enjoy living and
they're like we do it then get rid of it
yeah of course well the guy that they
were that top scientist that went
missing that asked a question even asked
a question and you know and then yeah
obviously you saw this stuff in
Congressional testimony during Peak it
was like the fouchy emails versus the
fauci TV appearances you know on the
cover of like Vogue magazine or whatever
the hell he was doing like
they were literally a country like you
cannot so was he lying to the American
public or was he lying to his colleagues
in medicine because they were literally
Polar Opposites one of them has to be a
lie no everything so who is he lying to
it like yeah science I'm not sure if
you're aware of this he is the science
besides and again because that became
the religion of the left and he was The
High Priestess of that religion you
could not you could not question it and
but I'm like but how do you not question
a polar opposite like you can't two
things
that are opposite cannot be true at the
same time because she declared himself
God he said I am truth he literally did
I am the science what well you know that
guy spent his life getting his ass
kicked and I think that could be good
for a lot of people but like you know he
was just bitter at the world and he got
a moment to be like that star and he he
took it and you know your health your
grandmother's life your children's lives
their well-being their education your
business our economy meant nothing unto
him relative to him being on another
magazine cover getting a little bit of
attention from a celebrity none of it
meant I I I I know it is early you
mentioned that and but I'll try asking
anyway do you uh intend to be working on
your father's Administration I don't
know maybe that's you know not
officially you know I I I'd love to
maybe be in there as an advisor were you
an advisor last time yes but like I just
sort of do these things you know like I
just go out there and I campaign I don't
you know what I mean like so I I know
what I'm good at and I'm sort of I just
I stick to my Lane but I think in this
one I I now know and I've spent so much
time out there you know fundraising for
republicans and fighting these battles
and like I just feel like I'm I'm very
close to the ground on these things so
I'd be like get we're not hiring that
person here's why here's the person you
should hire or the people you should
talk to about that job the reason I ask
is because I think you're uh probably
the second most popular Trump as you
also mentioned the second most
subpoenaed and yes investigated but uh I
also think that you have a very good ear
to the cultural issues that are
entrenched in our politics and I think
your debt would benefit greatly from
listening to you yeah no listen that's
what I do I mean it's sort of become
you know it really de facto my job is
like it means something to me like I
promise you it was a lot easier to be a
real estate developer from New York and
be invited to the cool person party and
like you know yeah I could when I was
young I could go to any Club in New York
I wanted and I got tables like it's like
I don't even want to try now it's like
you know and by the way there's a lot
there's plenty of people are like you
know sort of closet thumbs up like but
they won't say it out loud so it's not
the the end of the world but it's it's
just it's just so different that uh but
for me I I actually believe this stuff
I've always been you know
in that fight I've always been a
conservative you know even again I
shouldn't be but because of you know the
upbringing I talked about with my
grandfather from communist Czech
Slovakia I got a taste of that I
understood it you know then spending
time in that you know sort of you know
eighth grade through 12th grade and you
know Rust Belt Pennsylvania like my
friends were from these places I saw
what those decisions and those policies
my father's been really concerned I mean
he was talking about you know at the
time it was Japan you know taking
advantage of us in trade like China is
now but this is from like the 80s on
Oprah like he's been very consistent
about these issues and I saw it sort of
peripherally in my life and you know now
it's sort of become that like I'm out
there fighting for these things I got
five young kids I wanna let them grow up
in a country that like I recognize and I
see just how quickly it's all changed I
see like the conversations we're having
today the the hills to die on for the
Democrat Party
like five years ago we'd be like come on
come on like you can't like no way yeah
and yet it's happening it's it it's so
fast the erosion of decency and
everything we believe in and like we got
to fight against that and if I have a
good base and I have a following and I
can use that like that's more important
than anything else I could be doing I
want to show you some articles uh from
back in the day this one is from voxas
Donald Trump is the perfect moderate and
they put moderate in quotes they're not
actually calling Donald Trump a moderate
they're insulting him yes what they go
on and say is why we mistake extremists
for moderates but hold on there a minute
Ezra Klein who wrote this
this is from mat Iglesias two years
later Trump won by running as a moderate
Republican that is is actually serious
he says his undoing will be that he
isn't governing like one by the way
actually made that claim and I think
most reasonable people who actually have
paid attention to politics over the past
few decades view your dad he's been
called a New York uh a New York Democrat
a traditional liberal who's now running
as a conservative because the left has
gone so insane that now being a a
moderate is considered far right by the
Press well I think I by the way I think
that's accurate uh you know there's no
question I mean you know Kennedy today
would be all right are you kidding yeah
you know he'd be a Nazi and he'd be all
the things that you know we apparently
are and like give that cartoon where the
World War II soldiers get transported
yeah sure yeah yeah so we did a cartoon
a few years ago where a bunch of Lefty
sjws like build a time machine because
they want to bring back the guys who
defeated Nazis to fight the Nazis and
they bring them back and they're just
horrified by what these World War II
veterans are saying yeah but I mean
segregation there are sexual political
positions yeah yeah I look at antify and
I'm like please explain to me like based
on your actions how are you anti the far
part yeah I mean well it feels like if
you have a even a understanding of
history that they are actually acting
like the fascists that they seem to that
they pretend to protect us from I don't
understand I can explain this
correct marketing first yes no I can
explain this uh and and to be fair to
them they're actually correct the
fascists were traditionalists they were
authoritarian and more traditionalist
and the Communists were Progressive and
authoritarian so the authoritarian thing
is they have that in common but they
want to destroy the family they want to
destroy Traditional Values erase culture
and then build their own weird Marxist
garbage but it's weird
burning books and this kind of stuff I'm
like I don't know so you're right maybe
the end result of it but the the actions
uh sort their protest antifa they
genuinely believe they're they're
anti-fascist because they think fascism
is family it should be actually that's
that's literally that's a better answer
that's literally true that's how they
understand it the thing about fascism is
it's very nebulous and it can fit into
many different containers like the
question is what is the
you know ethos of the people of the
country who are living under Fascism and
then the state is supposed to fully
embody that like Benito Mussolini and
Giovanni Gentile Wright in the origin of
doctrine of fascism nothing of value
human or spiritual can exist outside the
state and the state must be above all
including the church which are all
things that the left believes right and
so it is kind of a fascist system
because they're saying our ethos is a
progressive ethos and so the fascist
state must Embrace progressivism
so they are Fascist
well there you go yeah
violent yeah very much very much well
this is also like fat fast
which part like the fashion the whole
metaphor comes from a bum a bundle of
sticks we're stronger together I mean
yeah there's truth in the fact that
people are stronger together but when
you become so collectivized that you
lose all individuality that's a very
serious problem and you see that with
lefties when you get them away from
their group they're not quite as far to
the left when you have a one-on-one
conversation I've said this before there
are only leftist groups not leftist
people what do you think about Patriot
front have you seen those videos yeah I
mean yes but like they look like do we
really want to pretend like it's not a
fed operation they
it's like the Gretchen Whitmer thing
it's like we're gonna find like the one
like you know meth head like right wing
guy and like get them to follow along so
they're gonna find one guy they're gonna
frame him as though he was trying to
overthrow the government you know
because you know it's it's so obvious
police yeah like hey dude those guys all
look like a lot like you know my guys
that when I had a secret service detail
like they're all sort of you know in
shape good looking guys
it's so ridiculous well and it's so
obvious it's like the same thing like yo
the Whitmer one's a great example it's
like so after it's a threat to the
governor I was like you mean after like
two years of baiting and fine you
finally found the one drug addict one
dude and it's like we got him we create
like you are literally entrapping like
they should be guilty it's it's lunacy
but again you don't even hear that story
you know you hear you know conveniently
right before an election that there was
a plot to assassinate like you mean set
up by like 12 people like people you
know and those guys get promoted and
those guys then are the people
investigating j6 I mean you know it's
not going to stay in their bureaucracy
and oh there's no consequence again like
we got caught we didn't do a great job
so let's start a rally and invite what
you know maybe we find one person dumb
enough to like go for this and and you
know hopefully we can you know sell them
a firearm on the side and they can carry
it and even if they have no intention of
using it that's going to be the
precipice for the investigation because
they clearly were trying to murder
someone now call me crazy but I think
the purpose of law enforcement should be
to prevent crime not invent fake
criminal plots correct to entrap some
random person who never would have
gotten involved with that activity if he
wasn't radicalized by feds in the first
place yeah you can't high five yourself
for saying we stopped extremists if you
created an extremist yeah when the
arsonists are calling the fire
department it yes it sort of loses the
you know I'm like I don't know like no
no it's literally that would be like if
the fire department went around trying
to get people to start fire so they
could put them out but they have no idea
Ryan long has that sketch uh you know
Ryan long the comedian him and Danny
polish Chuck wear their antifa window
repair and they're like at night we go
out and we smash the windows and we show
up we leave the flyer behind then we
show up in the morning we we fix the
windows for him that's hilarious that's
that's basically what the FBI's been
doing yeah and by the way meanwhile you
know when there's actual crime or actual
domestic terrorism like you know a guy
driving through a Christmas parade in
Wisconsin well we had him on our radar
but we were too busy trying to trap a
meth head like into a fake kidnapping
plot like they had they've been watching
all these people but they're either
you know they check a couple identity
boxes so they're not allowed to actually
pursue that because you know God forbid
you find someone who's a criminal that
you know maybe trans or otherwise or
just a minority or we can't actually
pursue that so we got to try to find
like the amount of people that were on
their radar that just magically slipped
through the cracks to actually go commit
a crime because they're too busy trying
to create a crime that they connect how
about just like try to prevent an actual
crime that's what I found do that it's
not that hard like that's what you're
supposed to do that was the craziest
part of listening to the opening
statements at January 6 which is you
know the government saying like we knew
we had FBI informants and so we knew all
about what was happening but then you
get the question of like then why didn't
you have additional reinforcements it's
something so bad was gonna happen and
you knew about it aren't you an
accessory to the crime yeah and then
they say well Trump you know he
authorized the National Guard but well
he can't but he couldn't by law send
them there you have to get either Nancy
Pelosi or Muriel Bowser the DC mayor
so they said well Trump didn't do
anything I was like he literally offered
it's almost like listen it's it's almost
like you know and it's strange we don't
hear about the bombs planted at the DNC
or the RNC anymore like oh like you'll
disappear you think that that would be a
really big story unless
it was all all set up
right and you got what you wanted out of
the other part of the setup if the other
thing didn't happen quite that way the
bombs would have been a really big deal
but again I don't know how far we can go
down this Rabbit Hole you know well in
regular YouTube but we got a lot to talk
about in the members section so maybe
what we'll do is like right when we wrap
we'll just start the members uh members
show right away but we're gonna go to
super chats right now and read comments
from y'all and take some of your
questions if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button and
subscribe to this channel but uh more
importantly go to timcast.com click join
us become a member at about 10 or so p.m
we will put up the members only
uncensored show so we can talk about a
lot more stuff uh and uh current news
goings on it'll be a lot of fun but for
now let's read what y'all got to say
Lizzy K says hey Tim love the show Joe
Biden was born closer to Lincoln's
presidency than his own Lincoln's
assassination was 4 14 1865 to Joe's
birth 11 2042 is 77 years seven months
and six days Joe's birth to his
inauguration is 78 years two months
pretty wild
yeah that's kind of crazy if you think
about it yeah that means like Joe Biden
could have a grandfather who was around
for
the Lincoln presidency yeah his name is
John Wilkes Booth yeah yeah it goes it's
that that we conspiracies that deep
could you imagine Joe bidenberg my
grandfather told me his stories man
about President Lincoln and his hairy
legs too
all right I'm not your buddy guy says
let's make saying you're fired great
again I think that's right yes that that
is that would be my policy decision if I
have any influence over it whatsoever
Matthew recantes is in regard to your
conversation about bears in a previous
stream Annie Oakley killed a 500 pound
bear with a 22 through the eye socket
wow without feminism I just did it yeah
it's possible without girl power yeah
that's amazing
yeah it's wild
Steve's Steven says Donald after seeing
how deep the swamp runs do you have any
political aspirations
it's interesting people ask me that a
lot uh maybe uh right now I honestly I
feel like I can almost do more not being
a part of it does that make sense yeah
you got to play by rules you got to do
this you gotta like so I can do that I
can I can help people along the way guys
that I really like try to help them get
them there and actually not have to deal
with like the nonsense that is so
prevalent in there so again I think
there's a component of it I like I love
being in the fight I actually like a lot
of the stuff that Republicans aren't
traditionally good at like actually
getting in the mud and fighting
um I I don't know that I want the day
job right now but that doesn't mean it's
it's working would you want to do it in
New York or Florida because I feel like
New York needs you more I I I'm never
going back to New York like you know I
kept my cabin upstairs I'm just not
doing it you know I initially you go
down the tax code like if they reverse
the tax code I'm not going it's just so
different yeah yeah you know like but we
got I gotta read this oh Anthony
Brownlee says Donald Trump was the best
president we've ever had and I hope
Junior will run in the future thanks for
everything you and your father have done
for for our country I appreciate that
guys for that honestly that stuff that
when you see that and I see it a lot you
go out to dinner and some you know I've
had this man it was hard a couple weeks
ago I was out dinner took my son and he
wanted to go get sushi and a little
weird but like this Marine sat next and
like I go to pay and this Marine had
picked up our dinner just as a thank you
for like I'm like wait dude you can't
like come on I it but it was like you
could see it was legitimately gonna be
like insulted if I wasn't gonna do it
and I was just like it's
like that's what makes all the BS all
the inquisitions all the 50 hours of
tech like when you see that like if it
actually makes a difference in someone's
life and they see that and they're
waking up to what really is out there
like that makes it all worthwhile and
that and perhaps that's what eventually
gets you to to actually you know do that
how did your son react to that moment
are they like kind of getting used to it
or is it you know it's interesting so
like for me it was different because you
know my kids like we grew up in New York
City and like that got tough for a while
before we moved to Florida right like
you know parents would tell kids
something they tried messing with my my
son a couple times I finally told one of
them like listen if someone's being like
that to you and like like you do
whatever you can to defend yourself and
you'll never I don't care if they throw
you out of school like you're not
getting in trouble with me yeah and you
know the kid messed with him he son you
know took care of it and like it never
had a problem again but like it was
really prevalent like you could see like
parents being vicious to like you know
then my kids are young right like my
oldest just turned 16 and this is seven
years ago right like it uh and the 16
thinks a whole nother story because
that's scary as hell uh but you know so
but going down to Florida like I you
know I went to pick up uh you know my
son at school and you know put them in
under a different name and this that and
the other and I go one day and you know
pick them up and like I'm looking around
like there's kids like wearing Maga hats
at a school and I'm just like oh my God
like okay okay yeah and and so you know
it's really interesting like down there
like you know like I have a hard time
buying my own dinner sometimes in in
Florida where we're at that gets a real
conservative area and it and it's
interesting it's not just like you know
the people I was sort of surprised like
we live in a really nice neighborhood
and I was like you know it's gonna be
okay that's a lot of New York New York
transport plants I'm like you know okay
fine like I was hoping for normalcy and
like you know the house next to me
before they even knew we bought our
house they had like a big cardboard cut
out like you have of Donald Trump like
in their window at that like this you
know and I was like oh this is going to
be the place for us it it's it's been
awesome so you know down there it's been
so welcoming for them because they see
you know people come up to me you know
whether every Walk of Life you know if
we're at a restaurant the bus boy love
what you guys do we've been kind of
treated like enemies yeah and so they're
like yeah oh dude like my kids were like
they thought I was because again you you
see it there there must be something dad
must be doing something wrong he sees it
now and it's like oh he's actually like
love like it's yeah and it was such an
important change like I think honestly
staying in New York for them
would have been like a psyop like
negative I I think it could have screwed
him up for life it would have hurt my
relationship with them it probably did
at some level because again you're a kid
you you know I mean it's why they're so
adamant about going after minors whether
this is with the grand stuff or that
like that is an impressionable mind like
it could be my child who knows me well
but like well this is someone I might
it's an authority figure there must be
something to it so Florida for us uh has
been awesome and I would never you know
like I said I kept my cabin Upstate
where I can go go there and I'm getting
high fives from all the locals it's cool
like it's different but like we'd never
go back to the cities let me let me read
this from agamemnon's gym bag Mr Trump
Junior awesome to see you here I respect
the hell out of you but why so why the
support for Bud Light and Anheuser-Busch
is it just Their donation history
convinced me to sell my puts yeah
honestly I think it wasn't even that I
think I probably you know when you talk
on air or whatever you like maybe I got
a little over my skis on something but
like the reality I was like it's sort of
weird when I look at all the other like
just terrible offenders it was just sort
of shocking to me that it was like this
one came that bad I'm someone who's you
know and I think you had Michael Seifert
on the show like you know I'm I've
invested in Public Square and these
companies that are out there like
literally doing the opposite so it was
an interesting one I mean I see Nike I
see all these other companies like and I
was just like I don't get like why don't
we do this to all of those so I think my
comments got sort of blown out of
proportion but the reality is like I put
my money where my mouth is on these
things trying to help the businesses
that are fighting on that one so it was
an interesting one for me because I saw
and again I think there's also a
component of it you know things are
blown up in a primary because like how
do we don't go Dodge Junior he's a live
I'm like no I was just making some
points but you didn't feel obligated to
protect no dude I'm not I'm not I'm not
crying for anyone like I like you see
what's going on watching the guys double
down now whether it's Miller Lite yeah
that was actually before it was before
yeah and now you saw the Ford commercial
your guys were showing me down there
with the you know the the Ford Raptor
that turned into like the car and
I'm like oh God like what's going on and
so yeah I you know again I'm not I'm not
any tears for anyone in any of
these things but again in a primary
season people are going oh yeah he's
gone so you know there's a component of
BS to a lot of these things and again I
think the biggest thing is I think if
you look at what I'm doing and the
companies I'm out there trying to
promote and support and literally invest
in it's the guys fighting for those
those culture battles so let's uh let's
yeah and I'll add to it I think when you
said it I think my response was like I
disagree no I think we should keep doing
it and then we moved on I didn't think
anybody yeah and I didn't even think of
it at the time so like I was saying that
I was like I'm just sort of surprised
that's the one like what like what about
like you know when you see the Nike
stuff and the Adidas I'm like why aren't
we doing like it just felt like there's
a lot more there it was an I guess it
was just like that's it's strange that
that was the one to me I think let's uh
let's grab this one Aaron presence says
Tim last week you talked about an only
fans model that was wheelchair bound due
to her implants well a few days ago one
of her implants exploded because they
were too large
yep
so we need we need a cultural shift in
this country is that like the trans
abled one where people are disabling
themselves they want to be disabled no
no no this is a woman who wants to get
fans on only fans oh wow so she got
implants all over her body they're so
large she can't walk anymore so she had
to get a mobility scooter to move around
I mean you got to pay the right thing
seems yeah oh man people's brains bills
like was she investing in her business
on only Hands by getting the implants
did she go into debt I don't know but it
was if your income is only fans I guess
they could write off the yeah
playing with 50 Cent dollars here for
the implants that made her unable to
walk and that never exploded just leave
me alone says dan Jr will you please run
for our next governor of Florida we need
a trump businessman to keep our state
free-ish
uh
maybe one day right now it's probably
not that time uh but I'll I'll continue
listen I promise I'm going to continue
to fight for this stuff because again it
matters yeah and I think you know we
listen we see how
you it's almost frustrating right you
see just how ridiculous it's getting
like and again I just wish honestly I uh
it's why I'm sort of disappointed in
some of the other Republican kind of
it's like you you know what you have to
just go all in like if we if everyone in
the Republican side went all in if the
people who support them became unafraid
like we'd actually win it like they're
not gonna cancel 175 million Americans
nope they can't do it but if you put one
guy out there at a time one guy has the
balls to actually go out there and do
this like they'll take them out yeah you
know they did that to my father they did
you know the most powerful man in the
world like they they can do that if
everyone's like oh I don't want that
because there's a little bit of a social
I'm not gonna be like but at the PTA
meeting I'm like you shouldn't go to the
PTA meetings at this point anyway
because the FBI is going to label you a
domestic terrorists but we should run
for our school boards so we can prevent
the indoctrination of our children this
is a good one Crooked Smile says
president Trump should host a TV show
firing all the corrupt politicians
responsible for all the many hoaxes if
he charged five bucks I'd gladly buy it
just to see them slimy politicians
squirm
I think if if there was like a
government program in the Trump
Administration where it was like 10
bucks a month subscribe and you get to
watch Trump fire corrupt bureaucrats and
politicians you can co-sign the order
the audience
votes for the person maybe like The
Apprentice but yeah like you and again
you know they'll say emolument Trump is
trying to enrich himself with the fight
we'll give the money to the U.S treasury
we'll pay down some of the you know 31.5
trillion dollars in debt that they're
racking up uh I think we could pay back
a pretty good chunk because a lot of
people would pay to be a part of that
I I just I think uh I I think everybody
would subscribe instantly and be like
you just turn it on all day and let it
run 24 7. you could actually probably
get rid of taxes right you know enough
people we're like we're generating
enough Revenue without taxes now because
you've just got the Bobs you know Adam
Schiff walks in what do you what do you
say you do here
all right Seth weather says conservative
dad's Ultra right beer will be available
for distribution in Florida next month
Don Jr will you put it in Mar-A-Lago on
tap have you have you heard have you
heard I've seen some of this stuff I
know that uh a bunch of guys were
starting you know talking about some of
that stuff so yeah listen get me some
information Seth weather has launched uh
uh conservative dad's Ultra right beer
in response I saw I saw it on social
yeah much like we have Jeremy's
chocolate I think this is I think it's
great that everybody that people are
basically launching alternatives to the
these companies if they want to get woke
they can go broke
so we ordered a bunch Seth uh we ordered
a bunch for here because uh we we keep
drink stock for our guests yeah so I'm
looking forward to to that let's grab
some more Super chats agamemnon's gym
bag says Sheamus and Company let's hear
your best Trump impression
uh my Trump's my Trump's not that great
but I can immediately I'm quite frankly
okay what am I supposed to talk about oh
no I'm always I'm only I'm only reading
this one because his son is right here
people to shake I won't name dabe some
people are saying it's a great
impression
what's yours
there's a couple things I you know I
don't do the Trump impression I don't
make fun of hair because maybe the Trump
hair Gene kicks in one day and so I was
like I'm just not gonna play with it you
know I'm just gonna leave it alone you
know it's risking too much it's a Karma
thing you know I'm just catching I'm
just not gonna go there is that what the
impression too you think you're gonna
get to his age and just sound identical
they already say I have the hand gesture
it's funny like one episode when I'm
doing uh my podcast on Mondays at six
and Thursdays at six uh on Rumble uh he
called me he's like I saw the podcast
cut it you got a lot less hands he does
do the voice
a lot less hands dot I go like how much
less hands he goes like 95 less hits
like I'm I'm going I I'm going 20 times
more
speaks with his hands too accordion
thing yeah you know so I guess I do that
too and I just I get impassioned and no
one's ever said I'm low energy you know
you get thrown out of the window of
Trump Tower if you're low energy in my
family and so that's great like I just
do it but he was like yes 95 less hands
so like I was like man I feel like that
was the pot cut like the the kettle
calling Paul okay so we're like you sir
King of the hand gesture a hundred
percent it's like when honestly the best
yes because there's a couple times where
I'm like we have to have a discussion
about self-awareness uh like you know I
would get a call sometimes when he was
president I'd get a call from the White
House and you know
done
you're too aggressive on Twitter
[Laughter]
yeah it's like that 80s like drug
commercial like I learned it by watching
you dance like it's like you know I'm
sitting there be like man like of all
the things like like I'm not saying like
I will listen to him on many things if
he's got business advice political I
mean the guy's done a lot he's
accomplished a lot I was like this is
the one place where maybe you've seated
like the moral High Ground here like I'm
like I don't understand like of all
what'd you do now I'm scrolling trying
to figure out what I said and I was like
I don't know it's like you know you
can't turn some things what I did from
you Dad yeah
all right what do we got here what it
should have been much nicer to that
recorder yeah
it says Sheamus you should animate this
fetterman speech like you did with
Biden's Corn Pop story oh I totally
should by the way yeah we've so we made
an animation a few years ago
of Joe Biden's Corn Pop speech because
when he's telling the story you kind of
can't tell what he's talking about so we
like boarded it out and put animation to
it so maybe I should do the same thing
with what fetterman said so we can make
sense of it no that that's impossible
yeah I I don't know because I thought
the Corn Pop speech was impossible to
make it was ridiculous but like the
fetterman thing is literally like just
verbal diarrhea like it's it's true like
you look at that be like the Republic's
over like we like you're packing up
folks like
riding the bomb down swinging the head
yeah here we go
uh here we go Robert Knight says Joe
Biden is the victim of elder abuse we
should highlight that constantly yeah
shame on Jill and his handlers well 100
I mean listen could
we do a nicer guy we've all had we all
know people or family or whatever that
have gone through these things as they
get older and stuff like that but like
that they can I always gonna run again
it's gonna be great what could go wrong
I'm like what could go wrong like have
you turned on like the news like we're
on the brink of World War III do you
ever feel like they're running him
because Kamala never picked up any
popularity oh I think like if they could
you know replace him with someone that
checks a lot of those boxes oh it's not
even a question I almost had the
impression they wanted a one-term
president was the oh yes like she was
the designated Heir and they assumed
that she had both brains and capability
and it turns out no it turns out she
hasn't either uh but like again but only
because they put her in there because
she checked off those boxes like it
doesn't take a lot uh you know to
understand that there's not really any
of that there and based on even the work
history and all that stuff like it's
it's all you know created Optics but
never real actual
accomplishment like you know you guys
actually next time talk to Kimberly more
about it because she worked in that like
San Francisco DA's office you just
understand what's you know oh she's got
a lot of ambition but that's probably
about it in terms of that but you know
that'll get you far
Jake says Ingersoll Lockwood was also a
watchmaker where Ingersoll lived and
made watches have some interesting
synchronicities with the modern trumps
as well
so I guess there were two books and
there was another book called
um what was the third one 1900 the
president or whatever the last president
and it's about like the Socialist
storming Fifth Avenue a hotel on Fifth
Avenue or something like that
people think that got some books for you
to read yeah yeah apparently up yeah I
haven't done much of my you know 18th
century uh literature literature 18th
century time traveling fiction is not uh
brushed up it has not been you came on
this podcast without brushing up I
really I really I'm a little bit I will
hang my head in shame the uh what is it
uh I think I hope Trump gives you
another call yeah exactly I can't
believe you haven't read about Barron
Trump it's part of our family's history
I think I think it was pasobic who said
his favorite conspiracy is that uh Steve
Bannon is Baron from the future that he
comes back in time to
I love that
that's amazing yeah I I so in terms of
the hand gesture thing
people on uh the freedom side of things
whatever you want to call it some people
call it right but then conservatives you
know they don't consider consider people
like me conservative or whatever but
we we can make memes and laugh about
Trump doing the accordion hands yeah
where it's like as he's talking and it's
hilarious and we can also make Joe Biden
cartoons of him on the Corn Pop story we
laugh at all of it but the left they
can't handle it no it's like apostasy no
they will they freak out it's blasphemy
sorry no it's blasphemy and this is
something I've noticed too like
when there are a lot to their credit
like there are some people on the left
who will like watch my videos and enjoy
them but then there are some people on
the left who they'll see my videos and
they'll say something like oh well it
was funny when he made fun of like Dave
Rubin but I don't like the rest of his
stuff it's like I was funny when I was
making fun of someone you don't like
right that's what you're saying like I
was funny when I'm in front of someone
you didn't like but then I just stopped
being talented when I was making fun of
people you do like it's remarkable I
feel like it's like everything else
though whether it's the attack on the
fam I mean they don't want any place
that you can go for Joy like you know
humor is gone I mean I think of like the
stuff that the funniest comedy of when I
was in like college like you know when
Chappelle was doing Chappelle Show and
stuff like that like you couldn't do
those skits today I mean no you know the
black white supremacist one of the great
skits of all time and like you'd never
get away with that today yeah uh you
know you're almost like you know when
you pull it up for like a refresher once
a year to be like ah that was fun like
you're almost like I don't know like
that's on my search history now like you
know can't Adam schiff's gonna indict
you for that
he watched the white supremacist content
Dave Chappelle it's crazy all right my
third nut says hey Don Jr I'd vote for
Trump however his recent 2A statements
at the Town Hall have me feeling a bit
soured why does he seem apprehensive
towards 2A support if he became Pro 2A
I'd vote for him without hesitation
I don't know I actually I don't remember
his Pro his two-way statements about
that I mean I know he's uh you know you
see what's going on right now I mean I'm
gonna actually do a whole show with
buddy I mean obviously I'm probably
about as big a 2A guy as I can that's
probably my like single issue vote thing
and you know I shoot competitively I
have my wife I'm a big hunter like you
know I'm gonna do a whole thing on my
show on Monday with my buddy George uh
Armstrong who's a manufacturer actually
in talking about all the stuff as it
relates to the pistol brace stuff coming
up and so I I didn't I must have missed
those comments on that but you know
what's going on right now and the threat
and the attack and the registrations and
and all of this stuff all without you
know done through the ATF and unelected
officials uh is crazy stuff and I know
there's a couple guys in Congress trying
to do something about it but
I don't think it's going to happen
before that so we're gonna we're
actually ATF oh 100 like I I like what
do they do you know the reality no they
don't they don't do anything they
eliminate listen let's talk about the
one at hand right the pistol brace
things expiring on you're going into
effect on May 31st the pistol brace
rules that allowed you know they're
saying it's the way around the SBR the
ATF built that that's their design like
there's times you know what hey you give
like the American redneck like a
blueprint this is the law they'll figure
out a way around it and I could say okay
fine if this was something that you know
people figured out a way around an
existing law to be able to get by
something they created this they wrote
this and now they want to make millions
of Americans felons for having millions
of pistol-braced AR-15s and saying it's
an SBR guess what even if it's an SBR
who cares like what's an SBR get it like
it's nonsense just like the NFA yeah get
rid of the ATF don't need them 100 like
that's a that's a big undertaking with
Congress no of course well that's the
problem right you know people are like
why didn't Trump do something with you
know the hearing protection act right uh
well because Congress didn't put it on
his desk like they work you know like
the the president doesn't unilaterally
make laws that's not how it works in
reality there was the bump stock ban yes
and then I think he said Luke is always
uh ragging on this is something about I
like to take him first and then
legislate afterwards or something like
that yeah I did I I wasn't a fan of the
bump stock band I mean listen I I I I
have dozens of guns like I eat it a lot
more than that I don't even say the
numbers uh I don't know that did yeah I
think the Federal Court ruled it
unconstitutional or something probably
because it's an accessory or whatever it
is like the whole thing listen but well
the pistol Bridge thinks a lot different
in in my mind in the sense that it's
literally ruled on by the ATF like they
created this law now they're gonna make
that people spend millions of dollars to
fix millions of firearms or felon and
again I don't like the back way and sort
of way of registering it now do I
register them
I I probably have to for me I'm not
recommending it to others but I know
that someone's going to see me with a
gun or they know that I have dozens
I'm not gonna get the hunter Biden
treatment that if I have and again it's
not like I don't have plenty of ARS that
aren't registered that aren't sbrs or
aren't pistol braced so it's like it's
fine but I I hate it in principle but I
know that like there's a solid chance of
you know if there's ever a hey I'll get
a knock on the door like the they use
the hostage Rescue Team to knock on the
door of Mar-A-Lago and if I have one
thing that's out of compliance I'm going
to jail and like I'm not getting a
mulligan I gotta I gotta ask you before
I run out of time um because we did ask
you this when you called in last time
about Julian Assange and a pardon and
you said we got a pardon these guys so
while we have you here I really uh this
this one's particularly important to me
especially some of my friends the what's
what's currently going on with Julian
Assange I think that none of this should
ever happen the man should be free I'm
curious if you want to elaborate or your
thoughts yeah listen I think we we got
into it last time I I didn't I don't
know if I fully sort of gave you my
views on it like and I think if you
would have asked me this in 2016 I'd say
it's terrible and you know same with
Snowden uh I can't believe they did this
if they put our people In Harm's Way you
know and now I'm looking at it and now
I'm looking at it in light of what we
found out about Ukraine and I'm like
wait a minute now that I've been a fly
on the wall right now that I've been a
subject to their you know witch hunts or
to their you know disaster whatever we
want to call whatever just happened I
think it's far worse than a Witch Hunt
frankly at this point uh I I unders My
Views have changed entirely I think
there was that time when I had that well
the American government and the FBI and
RCI they're doing it in our best
interest no they're not you know at that
time I would have said those guys are
you know they're a traitor to the
country or they're you know do now like
the guy that after that Time Magazine
cover maybe after that I was like so My
Views have changed yeah I think a
hundred percent you have to let them go
I think you you need those kind of
things to keep us in check it'd be
different if I thought we were
functioning as good actors but we're not
and that's evidenced as recently as two
weeks ago in Ukraine when you know
magically a 21 year old Air corpsman uh
you know has all those classified
documents about boost on the ground in
Ukraine when we're told explicitly we do
it that we don't we don't have and you
know I have a feeling that whistleblower
or that guy is gonna go to jail for a
very long time but the America like he
could have stopped world war three as
far as I'm concerned yeah like that's a
so again my sentiments now knowing what
I know and again maybe I was I was wrong
years ago but again I still I I wanted
to believe
right it's like Santa you want it you
want to believe that it's true when
you're you know like I wanted to believe
they're doing good things I wanted to
believe oh you're putting people In
Harm's voice like well no you're putting
people in harm way because we have boots
on the ground in a war we're not
supposed to be in that you're telling us
we're not in that we're funding
unilaterally against the world's largest
by volume nuclear superpower like that's
a problem
and you know again that one disappeared
really quickly which means there's
probably other incriminating evidence
that you know all of a sudden we don't
hear about this one so uh you know My
Views have changed like a lot of my
political views now frankly have changed
having been in the room yeah and and
seen in the Target been the target been
in the room and so you know that that
would be a big one for me uh do I ever
want to put our people in the field In
Harm's Way 100 no you know what I mean I
think there's there's reason you know
that has to be had here but like if
we're acting as bad like we've lost the
moral High Ground on a lot of stuff that
we you know that I thought we were able
to have and it's because these guys are
telling us what we're actually doing and
that's important I'll tell you my my
view on this uh uh I'm not convinced as
much on Edward Snowden I'd probably be
like okay fine you know let them come
home Julian Assange very different
Edward Snowden gets documents working
internally and then leaks them people
call it whistle but but but what he did
was he had a big Trove of documents that
he did not review and gave them out out
yeah there was a lot of important
information revealed by doing that which
I think is good we saw that they were
lying to Congress they were spying on us
but there's a big difference between
leaking whistleblowing and journalism
correct Julian Assange received
materials from whistleblowers and then
reported on it and they actually would
redact and they would make phone calls
he would contact the state department
and say hey we received these materials
we want to make sure nobody's putting
Harms in In Harm's Way and then they
drummed up all these insane lies to try
and destroy him because he was effective
so it's like people come to me about
Edward Snowden I'm like yeah okay I get
it but Julian Assange yeah obviously the
you know the no-brainer in that but yeah
listen you see it every day right they
disbanded the group at the IRS that was
investigating Hunter Biden and the tax
fraud it's like you mean you took it
over by like Joe Biden's doj took that
over because they had a whistleblower I
remember when whistleblowers were above
reproach like they uh you know look at
what they did you know Alexander he was
a great American hero you know maybe you
know offered the job the Ukrainian
defense minister and who the hell knows
what it you know grifting off of that
but like he was a great hero because it
was against Trump and so that again the
way these things are applied the way the
rules are the the way people are
protected as whistleblowers or thrown
under the buses whistleblowers uh we
live in two very different worlds and
I'd like to see actually just some you
know equal
equal treatment of those people I agree
we're gonna we're gonna move to the
members only uncensored show so head
over to timcast.com click join us we'll
try to have it live ASAP so go to again
timcast.com in the menu bar join us and
it'll be on the front page in a few
minutes smash the like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast do you want to shout anything
out Don Jr listen I guess just if you
like what I'm saying check me out on my
Rumble podcast on Mondays and Thursdays
at 6 PM conflicting a little bit with
our friend over here but you know but uh
there's always time to watch both we'll
just have to cross stream at some point
you know yeah talking about Shameless
plugs work my way we have to do that
we'll have to make that happen right on
Seamus Coughlin not the only person
giving plugs anymore feels good uh I
have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we're going to be uploading a
cartoon tomorrow that I think you guys
are really gonna enjoy this is uh this
is one about the fact that men have
periods now I don't know if you've heard
of this I've heard that that's science
yes it is science and If you deny that
you're a scientist
because look all I'm saying is what
Democrats have literally done by
definition what the left has done here
because trans women I'm told menstruate
and because trans men still menstruate
they have increased the number of people
in the world PMSing that's what they've
done that's all they've done so check
that cartoon out it's coming out
tomorrow and also on Rumble I have a
stream called shamer thank you very much
I'm Hannah Claire brimla when you're not
watching either one of these two
gentlemen's uh podcasts you should go to
at or you should go to timcast.com click
on the read tab you can see the work
from me and all of our other journalists
including Chris Bertman Cassandra
McDonald Adrian Norman you can follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best do it immediately if you
want to follow me personally you can
find me on Instagram at Hannah clare.be
and on Twitter at HC brimlow thanks so
much
um I wouldn't cross streams that's like
the first one
Ghostbusters reference
but uh beyond that fun show glad for the
members are glad we're going to members
only in a second here uh thanks for
watching y'all I'm uh surge.com on
Twitter please follow me so I can
misbehave a little bit more now yeah yes
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in a few minutes thanks for hanging out